WE'RE GOING TO CALL THIS HEARING
TO ORDER OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
WE ARE CALLED TO ORDER. MEDI
THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FRAZIER HERE FONG.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HERE HARPER.
MATHIS.
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD.
IT'S COMMITTEE.
WHO WILL HAVE SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS
TO? GO WITH MEASURES ON CONSENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B..
TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN.
FILE IN NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY THREE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE SIX FIFTY SIX TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIX.
WELL I REMEMBER FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY
NINE OH SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PC
OR ONE SEVENTY THREE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX
IT'S YOUR TWENTY. TWO TWENTY TWO
ZERO TWO. FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
ACR TWO ZERO FIVE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
ACR TWO ONE FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS.
WITH ANY MEMBER LIKE TO REMOVE
ANY ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FIRST BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GIPSON SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FONG FRAZIER FONG.
AND SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I ANY BAKER. BAKER
AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THINK GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER ON A MATHIS
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
SO COULD THE SENATE COUNTERS
EIGHT ZERO WILL HAVE ROLLED IN
FRAPH SOME MEMBERS.
OF.
SO WE HAVE MEASURES ON FILE THE
OF FILING NUMBER TWENTY TWO A.
B..
THREE ZERO FIVE NINE BLOOM.
S. PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
SO WE'LL LOOK FOR.
THERE IS IN ORDER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS.
PLEASE COME TO THE PODIUM
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS LET ME
BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE STUFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE YOU SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED ON
PAGE TEN. OF THE ANALYSIS ON AS
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN UPDATES
THE LAWS GOVERNING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS AND
FRANCHISE NEW CAR DEALERS TO
BRING EQUITY TO THIS VITAL
RELATIONSHIP.
THE NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES CREATE JOBS AND HELP
OUR STE HELP SPUR LOCAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
THEY'RE OFTEN THE FIRST POINT OF
CONTACT BETWEEN THE CONSUMER AND
THE SPECIFIC CAR BRAND.
THE AUTO INDUSTRY AND THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF AUTOMOBILE
SALES WITH SOME LIMITED EGGS
HAVE EXCEPTIONS.
RELIES ON THE FRANCHISE SYSTEM
BETWEEN THE AUTOMAKERS AND THE
DEALERS.
THIS IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE BALANCE OF POWER
BETWEEN LARGE MULTINATIONAL AUTO
MAKERS AND CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERS IS A FAIR AND
COMPETITIVE PLAYING FIELD.
AB TO ONE OH SEVEN CONTAINS
NUMEROUS PROVISIONS TO ADDRESS
SEVERAL KEY ISSUES THAT WILL
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA CAR
DEALERS ARE PROTECTED. AND IN
TURN THAT CONSUMERS WILL BE
PROTECTED.
YES MEMBERS THIS IS A LARGE AND
COMPLEX BILL.
IT IS LARGE AND COMPLEX BECAUSE
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN DEALERS
AND MANUFACTURERS IS ALSO A
LARGE AND COMPLEX.
HOWEVER MOST OF THE PROVISIONS
OF THE OF THIS BILL ARE ALREADY
THE LAW IN OVER TWENTY STATES.
AND SOME PROVISIONS ARE THE LAW
IN FORTY STATES.
I REMAIN COMMITTED ALONG WITH MY
STAFF IN THE SPONSORS TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION.
I BELIEVE THAT MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT WILL BE.
THAT THEY WILL HIGHLIGHT CAN BE
RESOLVED VIA CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
AND FURTHER NEGOTIATIONS.
AND I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND CONSIDERATION.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS CLIFF COSTA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
FOR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLIFF
COST ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NEW
CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
FIRST BEFORE I START I'D LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR.
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THE TIME THAT THEY'VE SPENT.
ON THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE LAWS ARE
IMPORTANT NOT JUST A FRANCHISE
NEW CAR DEALERS BUT TO THE STATE
TO CONSUMERS.
IT IS WHY THE FRANCHISE LAWS
HAVE BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE.
EVERY FEW YEARS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE STEPS AND TO HELP.
ADDRESS THE INHERENT POWER
IMBALANCE BETWEEN THE
INTERNATIONAL AUTOMAKERS IN YOUR
LOCALLY OWNED INDEPENDENT NEW
CAR DEALERS WHO STILL OPERATE AS
FAMILY BUSINESSES IN EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOUR DISK.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN IS NOT
DIFFERENT FROM PREVIOUS
FRANCHISE BILLS.
THE DRESS SPIN
CIVIC AUTOMAKER BEHAVIOR.
BEHAVIOR THAT UNDERMINES OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE
LAWS IN THE BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN AUTOMAKERS
AND DEALERS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REYES IS CORRECT.
IT'S BILLS COMPLEX.
BUT AS ARE ALL FRANCHISE BILLS.
WE COVER TOPICS LIKE WARRANTY
REIMBURSEMENT WHERE WE WANT TO
FOLLOW FORTY OTHER STATES.
TO CREATE A STATUTORY PROCESS TO
RECEIVE.
RETAIL RATES FOR PARTS AND
LABOR.
STILL ANY UPGRADES WHERE WE HAVE
ALREADY REACHED A COMPROMISE
WITH ONE OF THE AUTO MAKER TRADE
ASSOCIATION.
AND FRANCHISE OR COMPETITION
WHERE WE ARE CLARIFYING THE
EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS THAT THE
AUTOMAKERS GAVE TO THEIR
FRANCHISE DEALERS IN OUR
FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
IMPORTANT PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL.
NOW FRANCHISE BILLS TYPICALLY
WORK LIKE THIS.
SEEN SEDIA DOCUMENTS.
USE OF BEHAVIORS BY THE
AUTOMAKERS WITHIN REACH OUT
EITHER THROUGH A LETTER OR PHONE
CALL TO THE AUTOMAKERS WE TRY TO
RECTIFY THE PROBLEM.
WHEN WE CAN'T RESOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITHIN SPONSOR
LEGISLATION.
WHEN THAT BILL COMES FORWARD.
THE AUTOMAKERS IN THE DEALER'S
BEGIN A PROCESS WHERE WE
NEGOTIATE.
SOMETIMES WE AMEND CALIFORNIA
FRANCHISE LAWS SOMETIMES WE
AGREE TO NOT TO AMEND.
FRANCHISE LAWS.
RECENTLY WE REACHED AN AGREEMENT
WITH HUN DIAGENESIS.
WHERE THEY WILL BE SENDING OUT A
COMMUNICATION CLARIFYING THAT
HYUNDAI DEALERS CAN CONTINUE TO
SELL? AND SERVICE THEIR
VEHICLES.
THAT ARE GENESIS MODELS THEY'VE
ALREADY SOLD SO SPECIFICALLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS IS
THERE IS COMMUNICATION THE
HYUNDAI GENESIS MADE FORWARD TO
MY MEMBERS. WHICH SAID.
WELL WASN'T CLEAR WHETHER OR NOT
THE CARS THEY READY SOUL TO YOUR
CUSTOMERS YOUR CONSUMERS.
WHETHER NOT WE COULD REPAIR
THOSE VEHICLES.
CLEARLY A MISUNDERSTANDING AND
HYUNDAI GENESIS IS GOING TO SEND
OUT A COMMUNICATION TO MY
MEMBERS
AND WHEN THEY DO DO THAT THE
AUTHOR AND US HAS AGREED TO
REMOVE THAT PROVISION.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
FRANCHISE BILL WORKING TO REACH
COMPROMISES.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS WHERE LATER
THIS WEEK THE VOLVO C. E. O. OF
NORTH AMERICA'S COMING TO
SACRAMENTO TO MEET IN OUR OFFICE
WITH CALIFORNIA VOCAL DEALERS.
WHERE THEY WILL DISCUSS THE NEW
SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAMS?
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THIS MEANS PROGRESS.
MATT.
IN CONCLUSION.
WE'RE REALLY ASKING YOU TO ALLOW
US TO MOVE THIS BILL FOR TODAY
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTOMAKERS.
WE ALREADY MEETING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR FINDING
COMMON GROUND.
WE HAVE RETAKEN AMENDMENTS ON
BEHALF OF GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS AND
SEE JACK WE HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENTS WITH HUN DYING NISSAN
IN THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AND
HAVE HAD PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS
WITH.
TECH MEANT.
WHAT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY WITH AMENDMENTS
WE'VE ALREADY MADE AND ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL?
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK OUT THERE ARE ISSUES
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
TODAY I STAND READY TO ANSWERING
SPECIFIC YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THE
BILL BUT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTEEN HUNDRED
NEW CAR DEALERSHIPS. AND ARE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR.
NEXT WITNESS TO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME IN HERE REPRESENTING
PLEASE AND.
HE BITUMINOUS HAVE CAMPUS MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
JAMES LOMBARDA SENIOR BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION. I WE WERE LAKE IN
OUR LETTER IN BECAUSE OF THE
MEANT AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
COMING FORTH THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WITH THE FINAL
OF.
FORM THE BILL WOULD BE AND AND
YES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL.
UP.
OUR MOM UNPOPULAR ZERO EVEN
SMALLER THAN. BIG CAR DEALERS I
MEAN YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW SOME A
VERY NEAR NEIGHBORHOOD IF YOU
LOOK AROUND THERE ARE MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS WERE VERY SMALL. AND
WE'RE HAVING TO DEAL WITH HONDA
CORPORATION THAT HAS MULTI
AUTOMOBILES ALONG WITH. OTHER
PRODUCTS BMW.
AND YOUR YOUR SINGLE DEALER
TRYING TO GET PARTS
EQUIPMENT AND AND.
MODELS TO SELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
THERE WAS A PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OR VOICE THEIR
OPINION ON THE AUTHORS BILL.
WE STOPPED FOR.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT CLEARLY PLEASE FOR
THE RECORD.
MY NAME IS JEAN URBAN. I
REPRESENT THE ALLIANCE OF
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. AS IT
IS IN PRINT TODAY AND IS IS IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
AS URINALYSIS NOTES WE DO THIS
PERIODICALLY.
EVERY TWO OR THREE YEARS OF BILL
ARRIVES REGARDLESS.
OF THE MARKETPLACE REGARDLESS
OF THE CONDITIONS.
I WOULD SUGGEST THIS IS THE
BIGGEST BILL WE'VE EVER
CONFRONTED THAT ONE FOR WILL
THAT THERE'S BEEN THE LEAST
EVIDENCE.
THE LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS HAVE
BEEN HEALTHY AND TIMES FOR THE
INDUSTRY.
NATIONALLY IN THIS STATE WE SOLD
MORE CARS THAN EVER BEFORE.
WE ARE SELLING CLEANER MORE
EFFICIENT CARS AND EVER BEFORE
SCHAEFER. ALL OF THAT THIS BILL
WILL IMPEDE THAT.
IT WILL INCREASE THE COST OF NEW
CARS.
IT WILL INCREASE THE COST OF
SERVICING THOSE CARS IT WILL
DELAY IN IMPEDE THE DEPLOYMENT
OF.
CLEANER AND MORE EFFICIENT
VEHICLES INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINES.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
CONNECTIVITY.
VEHICLE THE VEHICLE
COMMUNICATION VEHICLE TO
PEDESTRIAN VEHICLE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND LASTLY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY LET ALONE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES THEMSELVES BUT THE
TECHNOLOGY.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THREE OR FOUR
THE PROVISIONS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH YOUR.
PERMISSION.
THE FACILITY INVESTMENT ON PAGE
THIRTY FOUR.
I ASK YOU TO READ IT.
SAYS IF THEY'VE DONE SOMETHING
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING AGAIN.
ARE YOU SERIOUS REALLY.
THINK OF WHAT A CAR WAS LIKE TEN
YEARS AGO.
AND WHAT IT WILL BE LIKE IN TEN
YEARS IF THEY DON'T INVEST.
IN.
ELECTRONIC.
DEVICES.
TO DIAGNOSE VEHICLES AS OPPOSED
TO RANCHERS WE'RE GONNA BE IN
SERIOUS TROUBLE.
IF THEY DON'T INVEST.
IN SOME OF THE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE GONNA BE
REQUIRED LIKE ALUMINUM YOU
CAN'T.
DO ALUMINUM NEXT TO STEAL IT
DOESN'T WORK YOU HAVE TO INVEST.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
EXEMPTION THEY PUT ON IN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES.
THAT'S TODAY IN F. ONE FIFTIES
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED AS A
MATTER OF FRANCHISE AGREEMENT TO
DO MAKE ANY INVESTMENT. MORE
OFTEN THAN TEN YEARS AT THE
LOWEST AMOUNT NO AMOUNT IS
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL. THEY
COULD LITERALLY INVEST THAT
DOLLAR.
AND WE WOULD BE UNABLE TO
RESPOND.
I'M
THE SUBSCRIPTION ON PAGE TWENTY
SIX.
WE USE A SUBSCRIPTION RIGHT NOW
TO TEST VEHICLES BEFORE
PRODUCTION.
WE TEST NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
NEW POWERTRAINS
NEW TRANSMISSIONS.
THAT ARGUABLY WOULD BE GREATLY
RESTRICTED AND WHOSE RESTRICTED
ONLY US NO ONE ELSE IS
RESTRICTED ONLY THE FRANCHISE OR
ONLY THE ENTITY MAKING THE
EQUIPMENT IS RESTRICTED.
SO WELL AGAIN THAT WILL IMPEDE
THE DELIVERY OF NEW MOBILITY
OPTIONS AND NEW VEHICLES.
THE PEOPLE YOU REPRESENT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE.
STATE Y. RELEVANT MARKET AREA ON
PAGE.
TWENTY FIVE.
AN INNOCUOUS CHANGE RIGHT NOW
THE RELEVANT MARKET AREA.
IN WHICH A DEALER CAN PROTEST
THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD IS A
TEN MILE RADIUS.
UNDER THIS BILL IT'S NOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHO HERE CAN TELL ME WHAT THAT
MEANS?
DOES THAT MEAN A DEALER IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY CAN PROTEST
SOMETHING THAT OCCURS IN DEL
NORTE COUNTY.
IT HAS NO PRECISE MEANING AND
EXISTS NOWHERE ELSE IN THE
NATION.
THAT ALONE THAT ALONE WILL
THROW.
DOZENS.
PERHAPS MORE DISPUTES INTO THE
NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT FOR A
SECOND.
MR ROOM AS HE WRAPPED UP.
THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD IS
GIVEN RIGHT NEW POWERS PURSUANT
TO UNFAIR PROCEDURES. IN WHICH
EVIDENCE THE RULES OF EVIDENCE
ARE BEING MANIPULATED BY THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
THEY CAN INTRODUCE EVIDENCE OF
OUR ALLEGED VIOLATIONS ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS
WE ON THE OTHER HAND CANNOT.
THE BILL IS OVERBROAD AS
EVERYONE HERE KNOWS AS HAS BEEN
ADMITTED BY THE SPONSOR. IT IS
OVER REACHING OVER BROAD AND
SHOULD NOT MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
REPRESENTING PLEASING.
THE CURRENT MEMBERS BILLY GOING
REPRESENT THE MOTORCYCLE
INDUSTRY COUNCIL RECREATIONAL
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT I CAN BE
AS ELOQUENT AS MR URBAN. BUT THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
BULLSHIT.
IT WE NEW CAR MANUFACTURERS AND
FRANCHISE NEW CAR DEALERS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CODE SECTION
OF THE SEASON WOULD INCLUDE
MOTORCYCLE MANUFACTURERS PEOPLE
LICKED OFF ROAD. VEHICLES AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE LATE WOULD
WOULD BE BUT I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO SEE.
BECAUSE WE WOULD WONDER FOR A
NEW CAR DEALERS FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT.
NOR SHOULD THEY SET STATUTE THAT
WOULD AFFECT OUR FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT WITH OUR DEALS.
SO WE ANNOUNCED THAT WE COULD
BUILD A WORK OF SOME KIND OF A
MEMBER TO.
EXCEPT OR PUT THE MOTORCYCLE
INDUSTRY.
THE OTHER THE BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
ROSEMARY SHE HIM PRESIDENT
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY. AND WE DON'T USUALLY
TESTIFY ON THE SAME SIDE WITH
THEM MANUFACTURERS WERE KNOWN
FURNISHING AIDING CALIFORNIA'S
ARE A LEMON LAW. AND.
SPONSORING OTHER LEGISLATION TO
IMPROVE PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS
SORT OF A UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE
WE DO HAPPEN TO AGREE. THAT.
THERE ARE REAL PROBLEMS WITH
THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY IMPACT.
CONSUMERS SO WE REGRET WE MUST
JOIN IN OPPOSING THE BILL.
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY HERE
WHERE.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE THE ONLY
STATE IN THE NATION THAT HAS A
BOARD. THAT IS STRUCTURED SO
THAT IT CAN ACTUALLY OVERRULE
THE DMV SO IN THE PAST WHEN THE
DMV HAS ACTED TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND CRACK DOWN ON
DEALERS WHO WERE. ENGAGING IN
MASSIVE FRAUD AND OTHER ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THE DEALERS HOLD IT OVER THE.
DMV'S HEAD THAT THEY CAN APPEAL
TO THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD
AND GET THE CASES OVERTURNED.
AND IN FACT THEY SUCCEEDED IN
DOING THAT IN A CASE INVOLVING
CHRYSLER IT'S A LEMON LAUNDERING
THE DEALERS.
.
EXCEEDED IN OVERTURNING THE CASE
AND THE DMV HOW TO SPEND.
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF TIME MONEY
RESOURCES TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST.
CHRYSLER IN ITS DEALERS.
SO.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT. THIS
WOULD INCREASE HER POWER THAT
THAT. THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE HAVE
BOARD HAS AND WILL MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR MANUFACTURERS WHO
HAVE PRO CONSUMER POLICIES.
TO ENFORCE THEM FOR INSTANCE GM
ENTERED INTO CONSENT AGREEMENTS
WITH.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEAU SARAH AND
THE AG'S IN.
FORTY NINE.
FORTY EIGHT OTHER STATES AND
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
REGARDING.
OF THE SALES OF BY THEIR DEALERS
OF SO CALLED GM CERTIFIED CARS
AND THEY AGREED THAT THOSE COULD
NOT BE UNDER SAFETY RECALL.
THIS IS GM'S POLICY THERE ON
THE.
LINE FOR ENFORCING THAT WERE
CONCERNED THE BILL MAY MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO DO
THAT.
CHRIS WRAPPED UP.
WE WOULD ASK YOUR NOVA THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL
OR WAS IT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME ANY
REPRESENT PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON
JUST ADVANCE ON BEHALF OF TECHNO
UNFORTUNATES TO PROVISIONS. THAT
WE HAVE NOT REACHED RESOLUTION
YET ONE ON THE.
MOBILITY PROGRAMS IN E.
COMMERCE BUT WE'VE HAD WONDERFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE HAD THE SPONSORS WE HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IVAN ALL
TOMORROW BEHALF OF GLOBAL
AUTOMAKERS I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY ONE THING THAT WAS.
STATED IN REGARDS TO THE ARM.
THE NEW CAR DEALERS IN THEIR
WORK WITH THE GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS
WE SAT DOWN WITH GLOBAL WITH ON
THE NEW CAR DEALERS WE DID
PROVIDE THEM FEEDBACK.
MOST OF WHAT WE PROVIDED WAS
THAT PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
MAJORITY OF WHICH WERE DISCUSSED
TODAY BY THE ALLIANCE WHICH WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH.
WE THINK SHOULD BE STRICKEN FROM
THE BILL WE DID PROVIDE SOME
FEEDBACK ON SOME PROVISION SOME
OF WHICH REAP REFLECTED IN THE.
IN THE ANALYSIS BUT FOR THE MOST
PART THE MOST EGREGIOUS PARTS OF
THE BILL WE DO AGREE.
AS THE A NEW CAR DEALER STATED
THAT THESE THINGS SHOULD BE.
DON NEGOTIATED BETWEEN NEW CAR
DEALERS AND BETWEEN THE
MANUFACTURERS AND WE THINK THAT
THE EXAMPLE GIVEN IS A PRIME
REASON WHY.
OF THIS BILL AND MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS IN IT.
SHOULD NOT BE THANK YOU.
THANK. BUT YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC I LIKE TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MR MATHIS.
WHOSE WEAPONS.
MORE SO QUESTION FOR THE
MYSTERY.
IT IT SEEMS TO ME. THAT THIS
ISN'T QUITE.
FULLY COCKED AND IN MY.
PROBLEM WITH MOVING LEGISLATION
FOR IN LETTING MY SUPPORTER.
IS HE IN ALMOST ALL THE IN IN
ITS NOT NOT A PUN INTEND ON THIS
ONE BUT THE MECHANICS I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE QUITE THERE YET.
AND WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW AMENDMENTS ARE WE ONNA
DO THESE THINGS.
AND.
YOU KNOW ALL THIS COMING LAST
MINUTE I DON'T REALLY LIKE ME
AND I I I LIKE HAVE A BETTER
CHARTER CONVERSATION.
SELL ON A LAYOFF TODAY. I DON'T
WANT TO SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT
MIGHT COME OFF AS A WOMAN.
PUN INTENDED ON THAT ONE.
.
BUT SOME ARE GONNA STAY OFF
TODAY BUT I HOPE THAT. THESE
ISSUES GET RESOLVED BETWEEN
EVERYBODY SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT. WE ARE PRODUCING GOOD CARS
AND EVERYTHING'S GOING FORWARD
EVERYBODY'S BEING TAKEN CARE OF
AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE IT.
FINALLY TUNED.
AND FIRING ON ALL CYLINDERS
BEFORE WE KNOW IT THROUGHOUT
THANK YOU.
BUT SOMETHING IS. NO PANTS.
PLAGUE YOU TRY TO AVOID.
VERY GOOD ONES
I ACTUALLY A QUESTION FOR BOTH
SIDES
AND FOR. THE IT IS THE AUTHOR OR
EVERY TYPE TO ANSWER.
THERE'S THAT. I'M IN I'M JUST
MAKING SURE THAT I'M CLEAR ON
WHAT'S IN AND OUT AFTER THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WHICH IS A
BIG CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE TWO
SIDES.
FOR NON WARRANTY ITEMS.
WILL SOMEHOW BE CONNECTED TO THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR WARRANTY
ITEMS.
PERHAPS PUTTING A PRESSURE ON
PAID DEALER SHIP TO.
TO.
INCREASE THEIR NON WARRANTY
RETAIL ITEM.
EITHER TO SUBSIDIZE OR
OTHERWISE HAVE THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES CONNECTED. IS THAT THE
CASE THAT THERE'S STILL
CONNECTED AND IF SO WHY.
SURE.
.
GREAT QUESTION.
SIMOUN BAKER SO HERE'S HOW IT
WORKS.
THE WAY IT WORKS NOW IN TWENTY
SIX
STATES AS THEY COME OUT MAY LOOK
AT SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE READ
TELL RATE IS AND EVALUATE THAT
BASED UPON WARRANTY LIKE REPAIRS
FOR VEHICLES. THAT NO LONGER ARE
COVERED UNDER WARRANTY
SO THIS IS JUST THE EXPIRED.
WARRANTY IT'S IF YOU HAD YOUR
WATER PUMP REPLACED YOUR FIRST
THREE YEARS YOU'D BE COVERED
UNDER WARRANTY. BUT AFTER THREE
YEARS YOU WOULD NOT BE COVERED
UP.
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE USE THAT
EXAMPLE OF THAT WARRANTY LIKE
REPAIR FOR WHEN A CUSTOMER PAYS
WE JUST USE THAT AND PUT IT ALL
THAT INFORMATION TOGETHER WE.
TAKE A WIDE SAMPLE OF A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT REPAIR ORDERS AND
WE USE THAT REPAIR ORDER TODAY
AND SAY THIS IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THIS DEALER IS CHARGING FOR
RETAIL.
AND THEN THE OUT WE SUBMIT THAT
TO THE AUTOMAKER IN THE
AUTOMAKER HAS A PROCESS KNOWN
THE REASON WHY THAT'S CONNECTED.
IS BECAUSE.
ALL OF THESE OTHER STATES HAVE
DETERMINED AND WE DETERMINE AS
WELL THAT IN OUR STATUTE THE
LANGUAGE OF OUR STATUTES AS THE
AUTOMAKER SHALL CONSIDER.
OUR MAY CONSIDER.
MAY CONSIDER THE RETAIL RATES
FOR PARTS.
THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE SEEN
ALMOST NO AUTO MAKER ACTUALLY
CONSIDERING THAT WE.
WHICH IS WHY FORTY OTHER STATES
HAVE PASSED LAWS ST EACH YOU
SHALL CONSIDER RETAIL RATES
AND IN TWENTY SIX STATES COME
OUT WITH THE METHODOLOGY.
NOW.
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AN
INCREASE
AND THE PRICE ON CONSUMERS.
WE'RE NOT SEEN THAT TWENTY SIX
OTHER STATES WE'VE TALKED TO OUR
DEALERS IN THE TWENTY SIX OTHER
STATES THAT'S NOT HAPPENING. AND
FURTHERMORE THAT WOULD
COMPLETELY IGNORE THE FACT THAT
WE WORK IN A HIGHLY COMPETITIVE
MARKET.
NON WARRANTY REPAIRS ARE HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE WITH THOSE
INDEPENDENT REPAIR SHOP.
SO YOU HAVE YOUR MOM AND POP
GUYS DOWN THE STREET WHO ARE
COMPETING AGAINST FRANCHISE NEW
CAR DEALERS THEY DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH OVERHEAD THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIALIZED TRAINING THEY
DON'T HAVE THE. RIGHT
TECHNICIANS BUT WE ARE COMPETING
AGAINST THEM
WHAT WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN IN
THESE OTHER STATES IS THAT RATE
ON RETAIL HAS ACTUALLY. ROCKED
LESS EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THE DEALERS CAN BE MORE
COMPETITIVE BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING RETAIL FROM THE
AUTOMAKERS VERSES THEY'RE
SUBSIDIZING.
OKAY THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
IS DOES THIS EXACTLY WHEN I
STOOD KNOWING THAT WAS THE NEXT
QUESTION I HAD WAS IF YOU HAVE
THAT BECAUSE IT'S A. WHAT THIS
CAN DO TO CONSUMERS?
IS ALSO PART MEET BASICALLY BE
REALLY NICE IF IF THERE'S A LOT
MORE ANIMOSITY THAN THERE HAS
BEEN FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
INCOME IN THE COMMITTEE AT THIS
STAGE BE NICE IF WE DIDN'T SEE
IT. AND THIS IS WORKED OUT BUT
MY ALSO TRYING TO DIGEST WHAT IS
GONNA HAPPEN TO CONSUMERS IN MY
COMMUNITY SO. IF I I WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR THAT COUNTER IF YOU HAVE
ONE IF THAT PUTS UP PRICE
PRESSURE.
IT WILL BE MUCH SHORTER.
YES AND THE REASON I MUST IT IS
BILLS QUALITATIVELY DIFFERENT
FROM PRE PREDECESSORS.
THE BILL PROHIBITS THE
CONSIDERATION OF ANY DISCOUNTS.
NEGOTIATED WITH GOVERNMENT
INSURANCE RAINING THEY'VE PICKED
THE HIGHEST RATE IN THAT IT THAT
IN THE STATUTE. AND MAKE US PAY
IT EVEN IF WE OBJECT WE HAVE TO
PAY IT WHILE IT'S BEING
LITIGATED IN FRONT OF THE NEW
MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD.
A PROCESSES FOR WHICH ARE
DISTORTED UNDER THIS BILL.
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S A BAD IDEA
COMPOUNDED BY UNFAIRNESS.
NOW THE NEXT ONE HAS TO DO WITH
THE FIRST EXAMPLE MISTER IRVINE
HAD AYE AYE AYE AND I THUMB PAGE
THIRTY FOUR OF THE IDEA. THAT IF
THIS BILL WERE TO PASS.
A FACILITY WOULD NOT BE CHANGED.
FOR TEN YEARS THEY HAVE NO
REASON TO DO THAT.
YEAH I READ THROUGH THE REST OF
IT IN ITS UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THAT'S
THE CASE.
TO ME I'M NOT SURE IF THESE ARE
THE AMENDMENTS AFFECTED THIS
PROVISION.
I'M OF THE AUTHOR WANTS TO
ADDRESS THAT AT THIS ONE STILL
STAYS IN AFTER TODAY'S
AMENDMENTS.
OKAY. SO THAT'S THE CASE.
I MEAN JUST IN FAIRNESS THE
PARAGRAPH GOES ON.
WITH A MUCH MORE NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT THERE'S
NOTHING IN TEN YEARS THAT'S ONLY
IF AS I READ IT.
YOU KNOW FOR MODIFICATION IS
REQUIRED BY THE MANUFACTURER
DOESN'T APPLY IF YOU SILLY
ALTERATION IS NECESSARY TO
ENABLE THE SERVICE OF THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES SO THERE'S
SOME NARROWING. Y. WHEN THE NEW
CAR DEALERS HAVE AN INCENTIVE
YOUR ST STEEL AND ALUMINUM CAN'T
DO IT TOGETHER DON'T THEY HAVE
AN INCENTIVE. ALREADY WITHOUT
THIS EVEN IF YOU'RE READING IT
IS NEARLY AS YOU IT PROPOSED.
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS IF IT NEEDS
TO BE DONE MORE FREQUENTLY THAN
TEN YEARS.
I READ IT AS A DISJUNCTIVE
THEY'VE ELIMINATED ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES YOU ARE CORRECT.
WHICH IS AN ADMISSION THAT THEY
WERE PREVIOUSLY CAPTURED BY.
SO CLEARLY ANYTHING ELSE IS
CAPTURED.
BY EXCLUDING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
SO WE S. WOULD THEY SHOULD HAVE
AN INCENTIVE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
RIGHT THEY SHOULD BE LEADING THE
EFFORT TO DEPLOY THESE VEHICLES
AS OPPOSED TO RESISTING IT.
WE INTERPRET THIS.
READ THE TEXT
WE ARE RANDOM HELD THEM TO DO
SOMETHING MORE OFTEN THAN EVERY.
AND
YEARS EXCEPT AS RELATES TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES
THE ALUMINUM EXEMPTION AND AND
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES ARE NOT
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
NECESSARILY IF WE COULD BE THE
STANDARD INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE.
THANK YOU I I THINK WERE.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF DETAILS
THAT REALLY I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS CONTINUE THE BILL THE STAY
ALIVE SO THAT YOU CAN BE DOING
THIS KNOWING THAT ANYONE OF US
COULD.
YOU KNOW SEE WHAT ULTIMATELY
COMES BEFORE US ON THE FLOOR BE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE SUPPORT
TODAY.
.
AND AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
WHAT IT WHATEVER. SCANNED THEM
LECTURE BUT WHATEVER THE
ANIMOSITY IS YOU HAVE THE
CAPACITOR US NOT TO BE ABLE TO
GET SOMETHING
SENSIBLE TO US.
BUT THESE ARE TWO PARTICULAR
PROVISIONS FOR EXAMPLE THAT YOU
ARE THAT SHOULD BE YOU CAN AGREE
JUST BY LOOKING AT THE TEXT OR
OTHERWISE AND DON'T SO. KEEP
WORKING ON IT AND I HOPE THAT
WILL HAPPEN AFTER TODAY. THANK
YOU WITHOUT A DOUBT THEY WILL.
THE DISCUSSION IS GOING TO HAVE
TO CONTINUE. ON IT DID BEGAN AND
ALTHOUGH THERE HASN'T BEEN LOTS
OF DISCUSSION THERE HAS BEEN
SUFFICIENT TO LET US KNOW WHICH
OF THE PROVISIONS WERE.
OBJECTIONABLE AND SO THERE WERE.
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN BY
THE DEALERS.
MR FROM THAT I HAVE MS FREEMAN.
I'LL BE BRIEF.
.
I GUESS MY COMMENTS ARE MADE
DIPPED TO BOTH SIDES.
I'VE I'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT
CONVERSATIONS.
.
I WHICHEVER FRAZIER ON THIS ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL HAVE HEARD
FROM MY LOCAL DEALERSHIPS.
A VERY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'D
CERTAINLY ALL OUR LOCAL
DEALERSHIPS ARE SIGNIFICANT PART
OF OUR LOCAL ECONOMY.
THE KERN COUNTY.
BUT CLEARLY.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
AND I REMAIN AND I BELIEVE THESE
ISSUES ULTIMATELY NEED TO BE
NEGOTIATED BY BOTH PARTIES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOME BOTH
MANUFACTURERS. AND THE
DEALERSHIPS NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER AND LIGHT OF THE
CHANGING ECONOMY THAT WE
LITERALLY LIVE IN AND HOW
SERVICES ARE BEING DELIVERED.
AND AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
I STRONGLY URGE BOTH SIDES TO
COME TOGETHER AND I WILL WORK
CLOSELY WHICH EVAN FRAZIER TO
ENSURE THAT THIS NEGOTIATION
OCCURS IN GOOD FAITH BRING
FORWARD SOME.
I MUCH
THANK YOU MAY THINK YOU BUSTER.
MS FREEMAN.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO CONTINUE
BUT ALWAYS ARE MY RIGHT AND.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FLOOR I
HOPE THAT YOU DO VERY ABLE TO
WORK OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THANK YOU.
METRIC UNITS IT'S AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT REQUIRES.
DIALOGUE BETWEEN BOTH OF BETWEEN
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THIS BUT
PRIMARILY THE MANUFACTURERS AND
THE NEW CAR DEALERS I THINK AS
LONG AS WE CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION. WITHOUT A DOUBT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A ON THE FLOOR A BILL
THAT.
HOPEFULLY YOU ALL ARE GOING TO.
REALIZES A. GOOD ONE TO VOTE ON.
MISTER CHIU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A BRAIN DOES.
VERY COMPLICATED GET. A BILL FOR
IN I THINK IT VERY MUCH COOLER
HAVE A VERY OPEN MIND AND BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION
I THINK THIS IS A. THIS IS TO
FIRST COMMITTEE.
SO WE TRIED THAT OUT AS MUCH AS
WE CAN AND. ON CONFIDENCE WANTS
TO BILLS MOVE FORWARD WILL HAVE
A MORE.
I COMPROMISED BETWEEN THE TWO
OF A JUST ONE QUESTION QUICK
QUESTION REGARDING TO THE. COST
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
I DON'T KNOW YOU HAVE TAKING
ANY AMENDMENT OVER THE WEEKEND
THE DISCRETION WAS DEVELOPED
BEFORE THE WEEKEND. IS SAID TO
YOU IF THE DEALER CAN USE ANY
PARTS THEY WANT AND IF THERE ARE
NO CONSUMER SURVEY. THEN IF TO
DEALERS NOT OBLIGATED TO FIX
RECALL RECALL OF VEHICLES TO THE
MANUFACTURER'S SPECIFICATION AND
SUBJECT TO DEAR OVERSIGHT.
AND THE DAYS COULD AID RESOLVING
THE LAST SAFETY FOR THE
CONSUMER.
AND ARE WE GOING GO MOVING FOR
ARE WE GOING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
ABSOLUTELY AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
MAY I HAVE.
THE SPONSOR RESPOND TO THAT.
I TRY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER ISSUE I THINK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION.
I MEAN.
A LITTLE CONFUSEDBY YOUR
QUESTION FRANKLY WE DON'T SEE
ANYWHERE IN THE BILL WHERE WE
PROHIBIT. THE MANUFACTURERS
DICTATING TO DEALERS HOW WE NEED
TO DO A REPAIR AS IT RELATES TO
RECALLS ARE ANY OTHER TYPE OF
WARRANTY REPAIRS WE DON'T CHANGE
THE VERY NATURE OF WHAT THE
REPAIRS ARE. ALL WE DO IS.
CHANGE HOW WE ARE REIMBURSED
FROM THE AUTOMAKERS.
OR A GREAT THANKS FOR THE
CLARIFICATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
CLICK ON ONE OR TWO OF US LEFT.
.
MS REYES WAS LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE INTEREST OF HIS AT YOU
IN THIS BILL AND AT THAT THE
COMMITTEES.
INPUT
OUR END TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE TO ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS RINGS.
SO FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND BOTH OF THE SPONSORS AND
IN THEIR THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
FOR. ABSOLUTE OWNING IN KNOWING
THE BILL.
IT'S REFRESHING.
OF AND MIGHT HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS.
DIFFERENT PHILOSOPHIES BUT AT
LEAST YOU CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS GLARINGLY.
SO.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE THIS REYES.
ACCEPTING THE COMMAND COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY.
AS I TOLD BOTH PARTIES.
TO WORK IT OUT.
AND I FULLY EXPECT THOSE PARTIES
TO CONTINUE.
THIS COMMITTEES URGING.
TO CONTINUE A DIALOGUE GOING
FORWARD I DIDN'T WANT IT TO END
UP.
IN THIS COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER.
HE DID.
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL ARE OVERLY BROAD.
ALL OTHERS UNFAIRLY STACKED THE
DECK AGAINST AUTO MANUFACTURERS.
FOR EXAMPLE CARMINA FACTORS A
REQUIRED TO PAY THE RETAIL LABOR
AND PARTS RATING LESS THE NEW
MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD FINDS REYES
MATERIALLY. INACCURATE.
HOWEVER YOUR BILL BARS
METAFICTION IS FROM REQUESTING
AN AUDIT.
ON HOW THOSE RATES WERE
CALCULATED.
FURTHER IF THE BOARD DOES FIND%
THE RATE WAS INACCURATE THE BILL
PROVIDES NO REMEDIES.
TWO THE MANUFACTURES WHO
REQUIRED TO PAY UNFAIR RATES
WHILE PROVIDING REMEDIES TO
DEALERS IF MANUFACTURERS REFUSE
TO PAY.
SO LOCAL EQUITY PROBLEM HERE.
THANK I URGE BOTH PARTIES AGAIN
TO WORK TOGETHER TO CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE I APPRECIATE.
THUS FAR THIS BILL GETTING DOWN
TO THIS POINT.
I WILL RESERVE MY RIGHT.
TO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
I FLOORED IT ON THE FLOOR OF
CHANGES ARE MADE OR OF ANY
DRAMATIC CHANGES GO BACK THE
OTHER DIRECTION I WILL PULL THIS
BILL BACK INTO THIS COMMITTEE SO
FAST.
PEOPLE SAYS WOULD SPEND.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING IT
OUT MAKING SURE THAT THIS ISSUE
DOESN'T COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T HAVE A MOTION EITHER.
MY FIRST MY FRIEDMAN SECOND BY
CHIU.
MATHEMATICAL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER ARE FRAZIER
AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
THE BILL HAS FIVE NEEDS EIGHT
WILL KEEP TILT ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WISH YOU BOTH THE BEST OF LUCK
WORKING THIS OUT.
MR MOMENT.
OBERNOLTE YOU YOU SNUCK IN
WITHDRAWAL OR ANYTHING.
MR MOANED ABOUT TO SLEEP.
NEW BABIES AT ALL.
THIS OBERNOLTE YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB NINETEEN OH ONE.
THIS PROCEED WHEN READY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AB NINETEEN NO ONE YEAH EXTENDS
A NARROWLY CRAFTED SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR SMALL CITIES OF
UNDER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION TO REPAIR OR MAINTAIN
EXISTING ROADWAY INFRASTRUCTURE.
UNDER A VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES OF THIS
BILL WILL HELP SMALL CITIES TO
MAINTAIN AN INFRASTRUCTURE COST
EFFECTIVE WAY AND I THINK IT'S
JUST A COMMONSENSE EXTENSION OF.
ETUDES AFTER THAT ALREADY
EXISTS.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME HE
REPRESENT PLEASE.
GOT THERE IN CHAIR A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY MITCHELL FULL BORE
HOA I AM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
WE SUPPORT EVEN NINETEEN OH ONE
US THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND AN
EXISTING AUTHORITY HAS BEEN IN
STATUTE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE.
THE COMMISSION BELIEVES THAT
THIS WORD.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE MONEY
AND TIME WHEN DELIVERING MINOR
AND CRITICAL REPAIRS TO
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER.
SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS ARM WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AN AUTHOR
STAFF FOR WORKING THIS BILL AND
WE KILEY ORCHARDS WITH THIS BILL
FOR. THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NAY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME. THE REPRESENT PLEASE I TIM
CHIANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT.
STEVE ALL GOING TO HAVE THE
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT.
MY CORPORATE TRIPLING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
WILLIAMS ALSO MATHIS CHAMBER TO
DO YOU KNOW.
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT.
SLEEP IF WINTERS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS A CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE LIKE TO
TEST FINES FOR THE AUTHORS BILL.
IN MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
VOICE. AN OPINION OF THE AUTHORS
BILLS.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF THE FIRST BY SOME
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FONG.
MISTER A BLOOM OBERNOLTE WAS
LIKE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY COURT
REQUESTED I'VE.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING.
REFUSE PRESENTING YOUR BILL
HERE TODAY.
WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
STREAMLINED. DELIVERY
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS WHILE
PROTECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT.
YOU IS WHO MANY PEOPLE KNOW.
VALUE OF A DOLLAR IN THIS WILL
ACTUALLY PROVIDE A LOT OF EXTRA
DOLLARS IF WE CAN CONTINUE THIS
PROCESS GO FORWARD WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER IPHONE FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA. NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS FIVE AND HE'S ABLE
LEAVE THE ROLE CONFRONT SOME
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRING THIS BOARDS COULD BILL
THANK YOU.
MR MOMENT FEDERICO.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE THE OTHER
BONE MARROW MISTER TRAYNOR
MISTER MON WE DO HAVE SECOND
ITEMS ARE AT LEX?
RUTHIE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND.
PRESENT UNITS BILL BUT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE WOULD CLARIFY
WHAT A MOTORIST A.
BICYCLIST OR SOMEONE ON A
MOTORCYCLE SHOULD DO IF A SIGNAL
IS AN OPERATIVE.
I'M SURE WEEK YOU'RE ALL AWARE
OF THE FACT THAT I MANY SIGNALS
ARE CONTROLLED BY SOME KIND OF
AUTOMATION USED TO BE LOOP
SENSORS IN THE STREET THAT WOULD
DETECT THE PRESENCE OF. LARGE
MASSES OF METAL AND IDENTIFY
THAT THE TO THE SIGNAL THAT
THERE WAS SOMEONE WAITING. NOW
TO ENTER THE INTERSECTION OF I'M
SORRY BUT MISTER CHAIR.
CLARIFICATION FROM COMMITTEE
THIS IS INFORMATIONAL ONLY I
WILL BE ENTERTAINING THEM
EMOTIONAL MR OBERNOLTE SPELL.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR UP SO OF MODERN
INCARNATIONS OF THIS USE CAMERAS
WITH.
TECHNOLOGY THAT ATTEMPTS TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER OR NOT A
MOTORIST A BICYCLIST FOR SOMEONE
ON A MOTORCYCLE IS.
WAITING TO ENTER THE
INTERSECTION SO THE QUESTION IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHAT SHOULD A
MOTORIST DO IF THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS NOT WORKING SO I CAN TELL YOU
ANYONE AS A VICE WAS MYSELF
ANYONE WHO'S A BICYCLIST OR
RIDES A MOTORCYCLE. I'M SURE IS
HEADED HAPPEN WHERE THE SIGNAL
FAILED TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU'RE
SITTING THERE AND IN LESS
THERE'S SOME KIND OF TIMING
ASSOCIATED WITH A SIGNAL LOGIC
YOU WILL JUST SIT THERE WERE
FOREVER. WAITING FOR THE SIGNAL
DIRECT TO RECOGNIZE YOU AND THIS
ALSO IS A PROBLEM WITH THE
NEWEST GENERATION OF CAMERA.
EQUIPPED SIGNALS SO.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL.
GOOD MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN
MEET JAMES LOMBARDA ON BEHALF OF
BETA CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
RIDERS ORGANIZATION. AND A CABLE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION BICYCLE
ORGANIZATIONS I LAST YEAR YOU
PASSED OUT OF FULLER BILL. I
THINK WAS S. B. SIX NINETY FIVE
THAT EXTENDED THE SUNSET AND
SAID THAT. AS A CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND STATES.
CALTRANS DOES.
.
ROAD WORK ON INTERSECTIONS THAT
THEY WILL THEN REPLACE THE
CENTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
PICK UP MOTORCYCLES AND
BICYCLES.
.
THIS BILL AS A FOLLOW UP BECAUSE
HAVE WE'D LIKE TO GET SOME IDEA
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE
WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS UNLESS
THERE IS NO. ELECTRICITY AND THE
LIGHT IS BLACK.
YOU CANNOT PERCY.
AND THAT IS VERY DANGEROUS FOR
US TO BE AN INTERSECTION TRYING
TO MAKE THAT TURN WAY THROUGH
TWO OR THREE. OF LIFE CHANGES
YOUR AYE AND ALL LEATHER. AB
BOOTS HELMET. AND IT'S A HUNDRED
AND FIVE DEGREES IN AND
BAKERSFIELD USE THAT THERE FOR A
HALF HOUR YOU'LL BE DEAD. SO
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS BILL
HERE TO SEE. NINETEEN.
OHIO JUST PASSED A BILL LAST
YEAR DATA THAT SAID WE COULD
DIE.
GO FORWARD WHEN I HAS CYCLE
TWICE IT HAS IT.
PICKED US UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES THERE.
WANTING TO TESTIFY AS WELL
SUPPORT OF THIS HA HEARING.
HEARING OF THIS BILL.
CAME MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OR.
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN NOW MICHAEL
GUNNING PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION REPRESENTING AUTO
INSURERS.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW LAWS VERY
CLEAR.
IN FACT THE STATUTES SAY THAT.
IF THE SIGNALS OUT.
YOU HAVE TO ACT LIKE IT'S A STOP
SIGN.
WE'RE CONCERNED BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO DETERMINE WHO'S AT
FAULT IN AN ACCIDENT AND IF WE
HAVE SOMEONE WHO SAYS. HAY IN
ALL THE LIGHT WAS BROKE I TURNED
AND SOMEONE WHO SAYS THE LIGHT
WAS RED. THIS IS GOING TO CAUSE
DISRUPTION IN CONFUSION IN THE
MARKETPLACE PARTICULARLY ON THE
ROAD HUESO IN THE FRANKLY IN THE
INTEREST OF SAFETY. WE WOULD
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE IF WE'RE
BEING VOTED ON TODAY.
THANK YOU NICK BIGGER PLEASED
WHICH NAME HE REPRESENTING
PLEASE CATERPILLAR ABOUT
AMERICAN INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
ON LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
THEM MISTER GUNNING. A IS A
MOTORCYCLE RIDER I ACTUALLY DO
APPRECIATE HIM TIME TO DO BUT.
I HAVE CONCERNS.
I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST DURING
THE MISS HEADING BONE HAS BEEN
IN OUR.
OUR COMMITTEE SAYS SHE'S BEEN
MARRIED CONGRATULATIONS.
MISTER OBERNOLTE IS IT IS A
QUESTIONS OF.
IN HIS COMMITTEE.
MISTER HARPER OF COURSE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ASK A QUESTION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
DO WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE HOUSE MISTER DESMARAIS
SEASON BACK WAY BACK IN THE
BACK.
YOU CAN START QUESTIONING NOW BY
THE TIME HISTORY MIGHT BE READY
TO ANSWER ABSOLUTELY MISTER
CHAIR.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
SITUATION YOU KNOW MYSELF BY IN
A CAR I USED TO HAPPEN ALL THE
TIME YOU KNOW IN A IS A TEENAGER
MY TWENTIES BUT IS A TECHNOLOGY
SAID HAS ADVANCED. THAT HAPPENS
FARM FAR ABOVE FORM FOR LESS
NICK IMAGINE OF EVEN GREATER FOR
SMALL OF VEHICLES AYE SUCH AS
MOTORCYCLES OR BICYCLISTS.
IMPACT IS RECENTLY IS A IS A IS
A YEAR AGO I HAD A SITUATION
WHERE. A THE A LEFT HAND.
TURNS.
YOU KNOW GREEN. EVEN THOUGH IT
KEPT CYCLING THROUGH NEVER WENT
TO GREEN SO THE QUESTION I HAVE
IS ESPECIALLY IN A SITUATION
THAT'S BROUGHT FORWARD HERE. IN
YOU'RE TRYING TO CROSS THE
INTERSECTION AND IT DOESN'T GO
GREEN AS THE DRIVER. WHAT ARE
YOU SUPPOSED TO DO ACCORDING TO
LAW?
SO I.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS THE KILLER.
MY ASSISTANT ASSISTANT CHIEF
RICHARD ON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS HAVE NOT
TALKING THE MINISTRATION.
NOR HAVE WE BEEN CONTACTED BY
THE AUTHORS OFFICE ABOUT THIS
BILL.
IN THAT SITUATION JUST
SAYS REALLY TURNS FEDERATION
FOLKS MENTIONED YOU TREAT IF IF
THE IF THE LIGHT IS NOT
FUNCTIONING.
WHAT TYPICALLY HAPPENS IS
SOMEONE TREATS IT AS IF I IT
JUST A FOUR WAY STOP SIGN?
AND YOU WAY TO GO THROUGH.
THE OTHER THING YOU CAN
CERTAINLY DO. IN THIS SITUATION
IS MAKE A RIGHT HAND TURN.
AFTER COME TO STOP MAKE A RIGHT
HAND TURN. AND THEN SOMEHOW
FIGURE OUT ANOTHER WAY TO MAKE
YOUR LEAD TO PROCEED ON YOUR
ROUTE. I'M ALSO MOTORCYCLE
RIDER.
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL WE DO
CERTAINLY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STANDARD IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD JUST REQUIRE SOME TO WAIT
A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND ECHO THE STATEMENT OF THE
INSURANCE.
LOBBYIST WHAT IS A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT FROM FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF ENFORCEMENT AFTER
THE SAMPLING OF OF VEHICLE
COLLISION INVESTIGATE.
SO WE THINK THE POTENTIAL.
TRAFFIC SAFETY ISSUES.
CERTAINLY OUTWEIGH ANY.
CONVENIENCE I THINK THAT WOULD
BE ACHIEVED BY SOMETHING LIKE
MISTER I TO POLITICS TO TRY TO
CLARIFY THAT. ON.
YEAH IF YOU COULD HELP ME WITH
NOT FUNCTIONING BECAUSE IN THE
IN THE SCENARIO IS THERE
DESCRIBED.
IN THAT I'M ALLUDING TO AYE
IT'S THAT THE GREEN ISN'T COMING
FORWARD I TO ME THERE COULD BE A
DEFINITIONAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW THE POWER LINES ARE
DOWN THE POWERS OUR RIGHTS JUST
FLASHING REGISTERED LIKE THAT.
IT IS IT CONSIDERED NON
FUNCTIONING IF THE GREEN ISN'T
CYCLING THROUGH.
THERE COULD BE SITUATIONS WHERE
MIGHT BE ABOUT HOW HOW WOULD WE
KNOW THAT AT THE TIME HOW THE
MOTORCYCLES YOU KNOW THAT AT THE
TIME AND THAT'S WHY THE BILL THE
STANDARD THE BILL REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME.
IS NOT THAT SAME STANDARD AS NOT
FUNCTIONING AND THAT'S WHERE
SOME OF THE CONFUSION WOULD COME
AND IT WILL MAKE THIS DIFFICULT.
TO BOTH IN FORCE AND TO USE AS
A.
FACTOR IN INVESTIGATING A
COLLISION.
IN ON I KNOW THERE SHOULD BE A
RARE SITUATION.
BUT THE SCENARIO OF TAKING A
RIGHT HAND TURN I COULD BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC INTO SITUATIONS ONE
IF THERE'S NO U. TURNS ALLOWED
ON THE OTHER SIDE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY BE
TRAPPED IF THERE WASN'T BOND NO
RIGHT TURN ON RED SUCH.
RIGHT THERE ARE THAT'S NOT NOT
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT A PERFECT
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
ALLOWING THIS QUESTIONS THIS
ORDER CAN BE OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF.
THE AUTHOR BOTH THOSE CITIES
APPEAR.
SEEING NONE MISTER OBERNOLTE
WOULD LIKE CLOSE TALK I THINK
MISTER JERICHO CLEARLY WE HAVE
SOME MORE WORK TO DO ON THIS
THAT IS WHY I ASKED YOU NOT TO
BRING UP FOR A VOTE AT THIS
TIME.
SOARING TO KEEP WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT CLARIFY WHAT WE
EXPECT.
OF MOTORISTS AND BICYCLISTS AND
MOTORCYCLISTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
.
JUST JUST TO POINT OUT WE LEFT
THE. DEFINITION OF REASONABLE
WITTY PRETTY VAGUE WHEN WE WROTE
THE BILL BECAUSE WE INTENDED TO.
TO.
.
YEAH A TUNNEL DOWN ON THAT AS WE
AS THE BILL WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS SORT OF INTENTIONAL BE
TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT
IS COMPLETELY EMPIRICAL Y.
CONCERT NUMBER CYCLES OF THE
LIGHT. FOR CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT ELAPSES* BEEN DONE
IN OTHER STATES OR IF.
IF THE OUTCOME IS THAT.
IF YOU'RE ON A BICYCLE AND YOU
NEVER GET TO READ THAT YOU
SHOULD DISMOUNT IN CROSS TWO
LANES OF TRAFFIC TO GET TO THE
INTERSECTION I THINK WHEN YOU
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT AND SO WE
SHOULD CHANGE THE CODE. TO TO
REFLECT THAT FACT AS WELL I JUST
TRY TO CLARIFY WHAT WE EXPECTED
PEOPLE IN THAT SITUATION BUT I
THINK YOU FOR INDULGENCE MISTER
CHAIR WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON
THE BILL. LIKE YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE AND I QUESTION THE
LOGIC OF PROVIDING LEGAL DEFENSE
FOR ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
VIOLATIONS OF THE RULES OF THE
ROAD. WHEN TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS ARE AVAILABLE.
ALSO STATES HAVE PASSED LAWS TO
ADDRESS ISSUE YOU HAVE RAISED
THOSE LAWS WERE LIMITED TO
BICYCLES MOTORCYCLES AND BETTER
DEFINED WITH SOMEONE COULD
RENTAL REDLIGHT.
HOWEVER EVEN THEN SUCH LANGUAGE
CAN MAKE IT HARDER TO PROVE RED
LIGHT VIOLATIONS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WILL LOOK
AT GOING FORWARD IS IS HOPEFULLY
CAN WORK WITH THE HIGHWAY PATROL
AND OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY TO
DRESCHER CONCERNS.
BUT FOR ME ALWAYS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY TAKES PRECEDENCE IN ANY
SITUATION GOING FORWARD.
WITH THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING IT WILL MOVE FORWARD
TO MISTER THANK YOU MISTER LOAN
FOR SURE THEY THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
MR ONLY BE PRESENTING AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
BEFORE I PRESENT AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR I WANT TO SAY THAT I
HEARD THE CONCERNS RELATED TO
SAFETY STANDARDS AND LANE
SPLITTING PRIOR TO LAST WEEK'S
HEARING.
AND WITH THE INPUT FROM THE
BILL'S SUPPORTERS AND THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS IN BOTH
CAUCUSES WE'VE CRAFTED
AMENDMENTS.
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT TODAY
TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR IS A BILL
TO INCENT TO PRODUCTION. AND USE
OF NARROW TRACKED VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA BY GRANTING THEM HOV
LANE ACCESS IN THE SAME PARKING
ACCESS THAT MOTORCYCLES ENJOY.
HE'S VEHICLES ALSO KNOWN AS AND
TV'S ARE THE SIZE OF MOTORCYCLES
BUT PROVIDE BETTER SAFETY
FEATURES AND. AS THEY TEND TO BE
POWERED BY ELECTRIC OR HYBRID
ENGINES ARE MORE EFFICIENT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF YOU
TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY TO TEST
DRIVE THE NTV'S THAT WERE A
SITTING OUT FRONT OF THE CAPITOL
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO BUT. I
KNOW THAT SEVERAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE GERMAN THEM IN THE
PAST AS HAVE I.
IT'S A GOOD RIDE AND FRANKLY I
WAS PLEASANTLY SURPRISED THAT
EVEN I COULD FIT IN ONE
COMFORTABLY.
MY STAFF WROTE THAT I THINK
THEY'RE REFERRING TO MY HEIGHT.
NOT ENTIRELY SURE.
.
SO MY INTEREST IN THE BILL IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD WE HAVE A SEVERE
CONGESTION PROBLEM ON OUR
STREETS.
AND HIGHWAYS AND SEVERE PARKING
SHORTAGES IN URBAN COMMUNITIES.
AND WHILE THERE ARE MANY
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THESE
PROBLEMS NINE IS AS OBVIOUS AS
THE USE OF SINGLE OCCUPANT
VEHICLES. THAT ARE INTENDED TO
MOVE FOUR OR FIVE PEOPLE AT A
TIME.
ALONG WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE SUPPORTER
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT A
VARIETY OF TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS THAT MOVE PEOPLE MORE
EFFICIENTLY. AND TV'S FIT THAT
MOLD BY OFFERING CONSUMERS AN
OPTION THAT CAN REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION PARKING SCARCITY.
FOSSIL FUEL CONSUMPTION AND
POLLUTION. THIS BILL CAN SEND A
POSITIVE SIGNAL TO THE
MARKETPLACE OF BOTH SMALL AND
MAJOR AUTO MANUFACTURERS THAT
ARE CONSIDERING VEHICLES IN THE
SPACE WILL BRING THEM TO MARKET
AND POTENTIALLY HELP REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF LARGE SINGLE OCCUPANT
VEHICLES. ON OUR ROADWAYS AND I
HAVE WITNESSES HERE WITH ME AND
SUPPORT.
A PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
PHILIPPE IF WINTERS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NARROW TRACK
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR ATTENTION IN THIS
MATTER I ALSO WANT TO THANK SOME
OF THEM ARE MULLIN FOR CARRYING
THE BILL THE BILL SIMPLY DOES
THREE THINGS IT ESTABLISHES A
CLASS. OF NARROW TRACK SHERPA
SHORT TRACK VEHICLES INTO
DEFINES THEM NOT BEING LONGER
THAN A HUNDRED AND TWO INCHES
AND IN THE CASE OF A SHORT TRACK
VEHICLE. NOT A ANY LONGER THAN A
HUNDRED AND TWO INCHES.
NO WIDER THAN FORTY INCHES I'M
SORRY NO WIDER THAN FORTY INCHES
NO LONGER THAN HUNDRED AND TWO
INCHES.
IT ALSO MAKES IT SO THAT THESE
VEHICLES WOULD BE PERMISSIBLE
IN.
HOV LANES AND LASTLY WHAT IT
DOES IT A ASK LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT REGULATES.
MOTORCYCLE PARKING TO CONSIDER
THESE VEHICLES IN THE SAME WAY
AND AGAIN.
THE THE MEASURE ITS INTENTION
HERE IS TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT IS
THAT WE HAVE ADOPTION OF OTHER
SOLUTIONS.
TO RELIEVE SOME OF THE
CONGESTION AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE TODAY ON THE BUILT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY.
I THINK YOU A MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY OF THOSE WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE EITHER ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ELECT.
A SIMILAR TREATMENT. I HAVE A
QUESTION.
I'M.
COURSE VERY INTRUSIVE AND
LISTENS TO CONGESTION.
AS I REPRESENT LOS ANGELES.
YES.
ALSO UP I AM VERY INTERESTED IN
SOLUTIONS A CONGESTION LIVING IN
LOS ANGELES.
BUT GIVEN THAT THE THERE'S NO
PROPOSAL TO ALLOW SEVERAL OF
THESE VEHICLES TO SHARE THE
LANE.
THEY'RE STILL WRITING.
ONE BY ONE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
HELPS WITH THE CONGESTION ISSUE
I CAN SEE HOW WOULD MIGHT HELP
WITH THE PARKING ISSUE. BUT IN
TERMS OF ROAD CONGESTION IF YOU
STILL HAVE TO HAVE THEM ONE CAR
AFTER ANOTHER.
AND SINCE THEY DON'T THEY HOLD
ONE PERSON.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY CREATING MORE SPACE
THAT YOU NEED FOR THESE
VEHICLES.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO HAVE
VEHICLES THAT LIKE BUSES THAT
CARRY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SO COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT. I'M
SURE PLUS FUND HAS WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT LET ME JUST SAY
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING ANOTHER
OPTION FOR MOTORISTS
OTHER THAN LARGE.
SUV'S
AND AND AND BIGGER VEHICLES AND
LIKE THE QUESTION AROUND. A LANE
SPLITTING WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE.
CHP ON THAT QUESTION AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE DEFERRED THE CHP ON
THE SAFETY PIECE BUT THAT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF AN OF AN OPEN
ISSUE BUT I'M GONNA LET MISTER
POINT HAS COMMENT IF YOU WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR THE QUESTION SO THE
ANALYSIS I THINK DOES A VERY
GOOD JOB IN HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES OF THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT DID SUGGEST THAT
SOME POINT. WE MAY HAVE TO RE
STRIKE FREEWAYS I THINK THE
REALITY IS IS THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE ANY LARGER OR MORE
CAPACITY BUILT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THE QUESTION
BECOMES. HOW WAS IT THAT WE GET
TO SOLUTIONS WHERE WE MAXIMIZE
WHAT IT IS THAT'S CURRENTLY
BILLS? THESE VEHICLES I MENTION
ARE NO WIDER THAN FORTY INCHES
AND THE CASE OF THE SHORT TRACK
VEHICLE NO LONGER THAN A HUNDRED
AND TWO INCHES.
SO EVEN AGAINST MY LEAF THIS
VEHICLE IS A LITTLE BIT SMALLER
THAN THE ONE THAT I CURRENTLY
DRIVE SO THERE WILL BE SOME
NATURAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE
VEHICLES TO TAKE. MORE OF THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT AND ACTUALLY
GET MORE RIDERS IN PLACE.
BUT THE REALITY OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THESE VEHICLES FOR THEM TO
BE IN PRODUCTION
THE NEAR FUTURE THIS IS PROBABLY
THREE TO FIVE MAYBE EVEN EIGHT
YOU'RE A VENTURE BEFORE WE SEE
THESE COME TO SCALE. AT THAT
POINT I THINK YOU'LL SEE
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES AND THE ABILITY FOR
THESE VEHICLES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THOSE TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES
SO I THINK THEY'LL JIGSAW THEM
WAY THEIR WAY BACK INTO A WAY
WHERE WILL MAXIMIZE. WHAT IS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE BUILT
IT'S JUST AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO
LOOK AT SOMETHING OTHER THAN
WHAT IS CURRENTLY THE ISSUE
WHICH IS? MULTI PASSENGER
VEHICLES WHERE YOU JUST SEE ONE
PERSON.
DRIVING.
WELL I UNDERSTAND IN THE IN THE
FUTURE WHEN WE'RE ALL DRIVING
THESE IF YOU HAVE LANE SITTERS
REESE RIGHT FOR THEM. THEN I
COULD SEE THEM MAKING A
DIFFERENCE FOR CONGESTION AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
PEOPLE WRITING IN THEM AS LONG
AS THEY'RE SAFE. BUT TO THEN SAY
THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO UC
HOV LANE WHEN THEY'RE ONLY
CARRYING ONE PERSON IN THERE.
NOT REDUCING CONGESTION BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL HAVE TO BE THE
SAME.
LINK BETWEEN VEHICLES THAT DOES
THAT PART DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
TO ME.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT
I HAVE RIGHT NOW SURE AND AND
THE I THINK AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR
FOR THE ANALYSIS I THINK THE
BILL POINTS OUT TO A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AUTHORED BY MYSELF
THAT ACTUALLY HAD THREE WHEELED
FULLY ENCLOSED VEHICLES TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
TOBY LANE.
AND THESE VEHICLES HE ONE
QUESTION THEY ASK IS HOW MANY
PASSENGERS WERE THE ONES THAT
WE'VE SEEN THAT ARE BEING BETA
TESTED WHETHER IT'S FROM ALPHA
MORT MOTORS. OR FROM NISSAN ARE
FROM TOYOTA OR FROM COMMUTER
CARS IS THAT YOU HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE TWO
PASSENGERS PER VEHICLE.
ARE THERE ANY OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
AS HE NUMBER OF PROJECTS CLOSE.
THANK YOU THOSE QUICKER I
THOUGHT OF HIM. SIR VICE CHAIR
OF. ME TO SAY THAT MY GOAL IS.
THAT WE CREATE A POSITIVE SIGNAL
TO THE MARKETPLACE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO BE
INNOVATIVE IN THIS SPACE SO WITH
REGARD TO OUR THINKING OUR RULE
MAKING.
ON A WHOLE RANGE OF MOBILITY
ISSUES AND LOOKING FOR TO.
WORKING WITH THE CHP ANOTHER
SOB MOVING FORWARD AND I HOPE.
THAT WE CAN. MAKE THAT POSITIVE
SIGNAL TO THAT MARKETPLACE AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR MY VOTE.
I THINK WE MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER CHIU TO HAVE SECOND.
A SECOND MISTER BERMAN THE MAPS
ACTIVITIES HURDLE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. FRAZIER.
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHU. CHU AYE DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GET FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
VOTE IS SIX THE WONDERFUL HOPE
THE VOTERS.
A MISCREANT.
WE HAVE YOU.
LISTED AT FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE.
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON WITH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PERCENT
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE A
BILL THAT HELPS THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCE POOR OR THE AIR BE.
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY DESIGNED TO EVADE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR LAWS.
NEW MOTOR VEHICLES ARE SUBJECT
TO EMISSION TEST BY THE AIR BE
TO VERIFY COMPLIANCE. WITH
CALIFORNIA EMISSION LAWS.
HOWEVER DEVICES EXIST THAT CAN
ENABLE A VEHICLE TO FOOL. THE
EMISSIONS TESTING.
IN A PROMINENT EXAMPLE IT WAS
DISCOVERED THAT VOLKSWAGEN HAD
INSTALLED THE SO CALLED DEFEAT
DEVICES. AND MANY OF THEIR
VEHICLES
PART DUE TO REAL WORLD TESTING
DATA. THAT HELP DETECT THESE
DEVICES WHICH WERE PREVIOUSLY
UNDISCOVERED BALL IN LABORATORY
SETTINGS.
THE AIR BE OPEN AN INVESTIGATION
AND FOUND THAT EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND VOLKSWAGEN DIESEL
VEHICLES REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA EMITTED EXCESSIVE
NITROUS OXIDE A TOXIC
POLLUTANTS.
CALIFORNIA.
HAS MADE GREAT STRIDES
AND CLEANING UP THE AIR AND
FIGHTING AGAINST POLLUTANTS.
BUT VOLKSWAGEN'S DECEPTION WAS
PARTICULARLY DAMAGING BECAUSE
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE.
STILL EXPERIENCE
SOME OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE NATION.
THIS FACT COUPLED WITH RECENT
ATTEMPTS BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION TO ROLL BACK.
CALIFORNIANS NATION LEADING
CLEAN AIR LAWS MEANS THAT WE
MUST ACT UPHOLD SAFEGUARDS FOR
THE HEALTH OF OUR STATES
RESIDENTS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE WHAT
PARTNER WITH THE AIR BEING AND
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
LABORATORIES AND EXPERTS IN
ORDER TO ENHANCE. THEIR NEW
MOTOR VEHICLE EMISSIONS TESTING
PROGRAM AND DISCOVER. THESE
DEFEAT DEVICES
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE WOULD
ALSO GIVE THE A A RP THE ABILITY
TO SECURE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
PERFORM MORE INDEPENDENT
TESTING.
IN ORDER TO STAY OUT THE FOR IN
ORDER TO STAY AT THE FOREFRONT.
DETECTING CALIFORNIA'S AIR FROM
THOSE WHO WOULD VIOLATE OUR
LAWS.
POLLUTE OUR ENVIRONMENT AND HARM
OUR RESIDENTS.
THIS BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. WITH ME
HERE TO STEPS OF TO TESTIFY ARE
WILLIAM BARRETT SENIOR POLICY
ANALYST AT THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA. AND
BILL MCGOVERN POLICY DIRECTOR OF
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IN ONE BOOK.
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LAST WEEK
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
RELEASE OUR ANNUAL STATE OF THE
AIRPORT THAT FOUND NINETY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS. ARE
AFFECTED LIVING COUNTIES
AFFECTED BY UNHEALTHY AIR.
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA'S BY FAR THE LEADING
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION THAT
AFFECTS.
ASTHMA CHILDHOOD LONG
DEVELOPMENT LUNG CANCER HEART
ATTACKS A PREACHER DEBTS.
IT'S ALSO LEADING SOURCE OF
CARBON POLLUTION THAT THREATENS
PUBLIC HEALTH.
A RESEARCH ESTIMATES FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL HEALTH
CLIMATE YOU DAMAGES IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE PASSENGER
VEHICLE FLEET. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S STRONGER THE
NATIONAL VEHICLE STANDARDS HAVE
DRIVEN DOWN POLLUTION
SIGNIFICANT ACROSS THE STREET
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN MANY CASES CUTTING MONTHS OF
UNHEALTHY AIR.
GIVEN THE FEDERAL EPA ACTIONS A
FRIEND OUR ONGOING PROGRESS WE
NEED TO GET WE NEED GREATER
ASSURANCE THAT CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS OF WORKING.
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH.
OUR STANDARDS ARE TOO IMPORTANT
TO BE GAINED BY MANUFACTURE
DECEPTIONS US HAS RESULT
VOLKSWAGEN FIAT CHRYSLER THE PUT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF NON
COMPLIANT VEHICLES ON CALIFORNIA
ROADS IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE WOULD
ALLOW AIR BE TO COLLECT FEES.
FOR MANUFACTURERS TO ENHANCE
MOTOR VEHICLE EMISSION TESTING
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT WERE
GETTING REAL WORLD BENEFITS THAT
WE KNOW THAT THESE VEHICLE
EMISSION STANDARDS CAN COMPLY
WITH OUR PROVIDE. SO WE SUPPORT
YOUR SUPPORT. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WHO
REPRESENT PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BILL
MCGOVERN WITH CALLS FOR CLEAN
AIR IN SUPPORT OF WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE VOLKSWAGEN
SCANDAL. AND FROM OTHER PREVIOUS
AND PERHAPS EVEN LATER INSTANCES
OF DEFEAT DEVICES AND CHEATING
ON EMISSIONS TESTING.
IS THAT WE NEED TO VERIFY LEAD
TESTING WITH THE REAL WORLD IN
USE TESTING OF VEHICLES.
AND THIS BILL WOULD GIVE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO HELP THEM DO IT. I
WAS HERE LAST YEAR SUPPORTING A
VERY SIMILAR BILL THAT YOU
APPROVED AND ASK YOU TO APPROVE
THIS ONE AGAIN TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND PUBLIC. TO LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN.
OPPOSITION OR VOICE OUR CONCERN.
WITH THE AUTHORS BILL.
SO I DON'T KNOW QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SO DO I THE FIRST OF FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER.
AND SECOND PHONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN.
IS GROWING LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
TO OUR COMMITTEE WE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME. MONEY AND ENERGY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND IMPROVE OUR AIR
QUALITY.
AND SHE LIKE WE SAW WITH THE VW
SCANDAL IS JUST AS AN ACCEPTABLE
AND WILL NOT EVER BE TOLERATED.
I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON
THIS ISSUE AND HOWEVER WITH THAT
SAID WE ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT
EXTRA FEES AND.
IMPOSE ON MANUFACTURERS AND
ULTIMATELY ON THE CONSUMER.
OR SPENT WISELY WITH CONSUMER'S
BEST INTERESTS IN MIND.
OR.
CANNELLA IDEA THAT WOULD PROVIDE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
PROMISED PREVIOUS GOING FORWARD.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE HOLD.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
CHIU.
DALY. DAILY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE.
THERE'S NINE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
BUT PERHAPS A MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
EXCITING.
NOW.
ITS FIRST.
SOME REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
THE WORLD DOWN.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR.
RECEIVE WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
CAN MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FORMER
INCREASED PENALTIES FOR
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS.
THEY USE GLIDERS WHICH ARE
TRUCKS THAT RUN ON OUTDATED
ENGINES BUT ARE HIDDEN BEHIND
YOU.
TRUCK BODY PARTS GLIDERS CAN
OMIT.
TO FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY TIMES MORE
POLLUTION BECAUSE THEY ARE BLACK
BECAUSE THEY LACK MODERN
EMISSION CONTROLS.
I REPRESENT A DISTRICT WHOSE
ECONOMY RELIES HEAVILY ON THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY AND HAVING
BLINDERS ON THE ROAD WITH
IMPACTS.
SMALL LOCAL BUSINESSES AND AIR
QUALITY.
REFER SECOND THIRDS AND FOURTHS
KEEP GOMEZ RODRIGUEZ.
ARE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY LEGAL
OWN AND OPERATE A GLIDER VEHICLE
BUT THERE'S NOTHING STOPPING
THESE VEHICLES FROM.
COMING OUT OF STATE RECENTLY THE
VARMINT PROTECTION AGENCY HAS
PROPOSED REPEALING THE MISSION
STANDARD FOR HEAVY DUTY.
VEHICLES THIS LEGISLATION WILL
NOT ONLY HELP WITH THE REDUCTION
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BOARD ALSO HELP STOP THE THREAT
TO PUBLIC HEALTH WITH ME TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT. IS MATT ROMAN
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA TRUCKING.
SOCIO XIN.
SIR.
GOVERNOR JERRY MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE.
IS NOT REMOTE COVER TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD SPONSOR
AB TWO FIVE SIX FOUR. WHICH WILL
DETER THE USE OF HIGH EMITTING
GLIDER TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
RECENT YEARS OUR MEMBERS HAVE
SPENT BILLIONS TO UPGRADE
EQUIPMENT TO COMPLY WITH
COMPANIES TOUGH AIR QUALITY.
REGULATIONS.
TODAY'S TRUCKS A VIRTUALLY
ELIMINATE IS A PARTICULAR
PARTICULATES AND CUT SMOG
FORMING EMISSIONS BY OVER NINETY
PERCENT. LIGHTER GETS A NEW
TRUCK BODIES THE CAN BE PAIRED
WITH NEW OR USED POWER TRAINS
INCLUDING ENGINES.
LAST YEAR DUE TO ACTION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. PRODUCTION LIMITS
FOR GLIDER VEHICLES WITH
REPURPOSE ENGINES LACKING MODERN
EMISSION CONTROLS WERE LIFTED.
CARVE ESTIMATES IT JUST SEVEN
PERCENT OF TRUCKS OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT PLAGUE
LIGHTERS. IT WOULD ELIMINATE THE
BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIA'S DIESEL
REGULATION PROGRAM.
THOSE OPERATING GLIDERS WOULD
ALSO UNDERCUT CALIFORNIA
COMPLAINT TRUCKERS.
I WE ASK DR.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
LIKES TEST FIND SUPPORT HEALTH
SPILLED PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THIS ISN'T A MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN THE
COALITION  CLEAN
SUPPORT. THE GLIDER KIT LOOPHOLE
IS LITERALLY A LOOPHOLE THAT YOU
CAN DRIVE A TRUCK THROUGH.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THEY DO.
SO WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO KEEP THE EXCESSIVELY
POLLUTING TRUCKS OUT OF THE
STATE.
NAME HERE REPRESENTING PLEASE
WILL BEAR WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ALSO
SUPPORT THINKING.
IF YOU.
MAC OFTEN SEEN WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLICLY
TESTIFYING SPUR THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION ARE
VOICING CONCERN ABOUT THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER RODRIGUEZ
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
YES OUR SPORT ROUTES DRIVE OF.
SO WE HAVE A FIRST FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
THE SECOND BY SOMEWHERE OVER
HARPER.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR TODAY.
I BELIEVE THIS LEGISLATION WILL
DISCOURAGE BAD ACTORS AND
HOPEFULLY HELP MAINTAIN A FAIR
PLAYING FIELD. THANK THE AVOID
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS A
SPONSOR ALSO.
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY IS
SPENDING THE MONEY TO COMPLY
WITH OUR MANDATES AND WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THEY ARE NOT PENALIZED
FOR DOING SO.
THIS IS WHY I'M SO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
AS SECRETARY PLEASE HOLD.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE CHIU.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
IT IS NINE WILL HE THREW OPEN
FOR ABSENCE OF PREZZO MEMBERS
HERE OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GRANDMOTHER.
THERE WE GO YOU HAVE ANOTHER ONE
YES CULTURAL MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE INSURERS.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
RECEIVING NECESSARY WE RESOURCE
TO AID. THE FIGHT AGAINST POOR
AIR QUALITY CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
WAS CREATED TO PROVIDE REBATES
TO CONSUMERS WHO PURCHASE.
MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
VEHICLES HOWEVER MOST OF THESE
REBATES HAVE GONE.
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT
CONSIDERED DISADVANTAGE
ACCORDING TO THE DATA FROM THE
CV RP WEBSITE ONLY SEVEN PERCENT
OF THESE REBATE.
I'VE GOT TO CONSUMERS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SINCE
THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN
TWENTY TEN.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD HAS
HISTORICALLY DONE A POOR JOB
REACHING OUT TO COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE THAT ARE CONSIDERED
DISADVANTAGE.
THESE THEORISTS LIKE MY DISTRICT
THAT SUFFER FROM EXTREMELY POOR
AIR QUALITY LOW INCOMES AND POOR
HEALTH QUALITY.
I UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS WITH
THE CALABAR SCREEN DEFINITION OF
DISADVANTAGE THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED IN THE NOW ASSIST THEM
WANTED TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT
AS PROPOSED AN ANALYSIS.
HOWEVER WANT TO THANK ONE TO
THINK HOME TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE TO FIND A
MORE REFINED DEFINITION OR
APPROACH THAT TRULY BENEFITS
COMMITTEE LIKE THE ONES I
REPRESENT.
PART TIGHTENING AND REQUIRING A
REACH THESE COMMITTEES NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE INVESTING
WHERE IT'S NEEDED MOST.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME HERE
REPRESENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ISRAEL SALAS WITH
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC AND
SUPPORT.
Q..
ARE JUST SAID ABOUT THE BEHALF
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
SUPPORT.
HERE THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SINGLE ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO VOICE HER.
OPINION OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ WAS LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE.
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
APPRECIATED.
SO WITH THAT SAID ABUSE WHEN YOU
BUILD
THANK.
THAT SECRETARY WE HAVE A FIRST
BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN BURKE
BERMAN IS SECOND BY MR MEDINA.
LITTLE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER. HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
YOUR BILL HAS NINE LEAVE THE
ROLE BUT PERHAPS MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THINK IT'D.
SANTIAGO.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO.
PLEASE PROCEED TO THE DYSON.
ARE WE READY.
THING IS THE CHAIR I'LL BE BRIEF
THAT'S OKAY WITH A CHAIR.
EIGHTY THREE TO NINETY TO WOULD
MAKE A NUMBER COMPLICATIONS
EXISTING THE CLOSING LOOPHOLES
IN CALIFORNIA'S TOWING VEHICLE
STORAGE LAW TO REDUCE ABUSIVE
PRACTICES THAT.
THAT AIM INFLATING STORAGE FEES.
THANK YOU SIR TRAILS OF.
WITNESSES THAT WILL ALSO BE
BREACHED.
PLEASE UPLOAD FOR THE RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF BRICKS ALISON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TOW TRUCK
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF A WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR. ON THE STAFF AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF WE ARE.
CONCERNED AS EVERYONE IS I
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE SORT OF
BAD ACTORS AND WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO SORT OF IMPROVE IT WITH.
LAW ENFORCEMENT INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AND CONSUMERS WE'VE
BEEN PART OF. I THINK THIS IS
OUR EIGHTH BILL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN IN WHICH.
WE'VE BEEN PART OF.
HELPING ENACT.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL I
THINK WE'VE COUNTED OVER EIGHTY
NEW PROVISIONS THAT WILL GO
TOWARDS THAT GOAL.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME REPRESENT PLEASE
CATERPILLAR ON AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION I'M
PLEASED TO BE SPONSORED.
HAVE BEEN HAVING GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S DILIGENCE HOMELESS.
Q. SIR. MISTER CHAIRMAN MICHAEL
GUNNING.
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION I
THINK UP BROOKS AND I ARE THE
ONLY OLD GUYS AROUND HERE THERE
WERE AROUND
THE BILL PASSED THE FIRST TIME.
AND WE'RE SEEING THE ABUSES COME
BACK AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WORK TO.
TIGHTEN UP THE TOWING NOTICE AND
MAKE SURE CONSUMERS ARE AWARE OF
ALL THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE COMPANY
TAKE YOUR PICK THE RECOGNIZE
MISTER SANTIAGO WAS PROMINENT
BORN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SOON A
MAILING WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES REPRESENTING COPART.
THIRTY.
COUNTRY'S LARGEST SALVAGEABLE
OPERATOR IN SUPPORT.
Q. MIX WITH IS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME WE REPRESENT MARIO GARCIA
AND THE AT THE STATE FARM
INSURANCE IN SUPPORT.
IT WILL BE THOUSAND AFTER
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS AND
SPORT.
MY ANGER AM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT ALSO EXTEND IN THE
SUPPORT ON THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY THANK YOU.
DANIELLE AND ON BEHALF ALLSTATE
INSURANCE IN SUPPORT.
NEAR THE WITNESSES SINCE FOR THE
AUTHORS BUILD. IN THE PUBLIC
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THEY WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO WHAT WAS HER PAN. GOVERNOR'S
BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLUB
CASA HALF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR.
STAFF.
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH US IN
RESOLVING OUR ISSUES.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT THAT WE
ARE NOT ON ANY POSITION ON A
SPECIFIC.
BUT ALSO A TWEENER JACK MADONNA
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA AUTO
BODY ASSOCIATION THE AUTOMOTIVE
SERVICE COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA
WE WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS OF FOR WORKING WITH
US IN ADDRESSING MANY OF OUR
CONCERNS FEW OUT WE JUST HAVE
HUMOR TWEAKS.
BUT WE'LL.
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU
AS THE BILL A BILL MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
PRESIDENT SHALL MUCH LARA BE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT THIS TIME
WE TO HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF AND THEY'VE
BEEN A VERY KIND TO MOVE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMATIC. ON LANGUAGE IN
THAT BELT THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME PROVISIONS IN THERE
AYE WHICH ARE STILL PROBLEMATIC
FOR ASSOCIATION. ON BUT WE HAVE
AGREED TO KEEP CHATTING WITH
AUTHOR AND STAFF AND HOPEFULLY
I'M IN A SHORT TIME WILL ALSO
MOVE OUR OPPOSITION THINK YOU.
THINK.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE OTHER MISTER
PAUL.
UP I JUST REAL QUICK I PLAN ON
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I I DO YOU%
UNDERSTAND THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS A CONCERN ABOUT THE SIX HOUR
LIMIT OF ATTORNEY CALLS. AND DO
YOU ANTICIPATE WORKING THAT OUT.
PIPED RIGHT THE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AS TO SPILLWAYS FOR
ALL YOUR BEST WORK I ME WE PUT A
PRETTY GOOD STAKEHOLDER GROUP
AND PROCESS AND IF YOU'VE TAUGHT
AS YOU SEEN BY THE.
SUPPORT IN THOSE IN BETWEEN A
WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON IT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
CNN MISTER SANTIAGO WHICH I
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE
VOTE.
SECOND WE HAVE A FIRST.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
SIMILAR BERMAN FIRST O'DONNELL
SECOND.
.
SANTIAGO LOOK FOR YOU WORKING
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY ON THEIR
CONCERNS MOVING FOR NEW WILLING.
THE WORK. WITHOUT ALL THE SQUARE
YOUR BILL TODAY THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE.
KALRA THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN AND. BERMAN AYE CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA INEZ ARYAN.
O'DONNELL HE.
O'DONNELL I.
THERE'S EIGHT WILL LEAD ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MISTER CELIS.
THIRTY NINETY SEVEN. YES BABY.
CHRISSY WEARY CIRCLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
PRESENT FOR YOU GUYS SIMPLY BILL
THIRTY NINETY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR TO INCLUDE IN THEIR
EXISTING. ANNUAL SMOG CHECK
REPORT THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT
REGISTERED IN THE STATE
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES.
THE DO NOT RENEW THE
REGISTRATION AFTER FAILING A
SMOG TEST
AS REQUIRED BY THE DMV.
AND WITH THAT I'LL RESPECT YOUR
TIME ESPERANDO.
BUT ANYWAY THIS IS A SMART.
AS ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC THAT
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR THIS
BILL.
SAY NINE AND THE AND THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
A SAY NOT ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AS YOU KNOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIBEL.
NOW WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MR
MEDINA AND A SECULAR
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT SECTOR WOULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRAZIER.
FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
OF THOSE FIVE ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
.
OF ITS O'DONNELL HOW WOULD YOU
BE ABLE TO PRESENT ON. FILE
TWENTY THREE. A. B. THIRTY SEVEN
NINE.
OF.
PLEASE PROCEED WE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB THREE ZERO SEVEN
NINE WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA PORT EFFICIENCY
PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC PORTS ARE KEY
INTERNATIONAL GATEWAYS FOR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
GOODS AND ARYAN EXITING THE
UNITED STATES EVERY YEAR.
THE PORTS OF LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH FOR EXAMPLE ARE
TOGETHER RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY
FORTY PERCENT OF THE TOTAL
CONTAINERS CARGO ENTERING THE
UNITED STATES.
SUCH MASSIVE CARGO VOLUME RIGHT
REQUIRES A SMOOTH INTERACTION OF
MANY INDEPENDENT ACTORS WITHIN
THE PORT.
THIS INCLUDES SHIPPING LINES
TERMINAL OPERATORS ORGANIZED
LABOR RAILROADS TRACKERS
BENEFICIAL CARTOONS AND MANY
MORE.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA PORTS ARE
THE STRONGEST IN THE NATION THEY
CONTINUE TO FACE NEW AND COMPLEX
EFFICIENCY CHALLENGES INCLUDING
INCREASED TRADE VOLUMES.
DEPLOYMENT OF LARGER SHIPS AND
INDUSTRY COMPLEXITY.
IN ORDER FOR CALIFORNIA PORTS TO
CONTINUE TO SUCCESSFULLY COMPETE
IN THE GLOBAL MARKETPLACE THEY
MUST FIND NEW WAYS TO READ
CONGESTION. AND CARGO DELAY AB
THREE ZERO SEVEN NINE PROVIDE
PROVIDES THE FRAMEWORK NECESSARY
FOR THE STATE TO PARTNER WITH
PORTS AND DELIVER RESOURCE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED FOR STRATEGIC
IMPROVEMENTS AND PORTS
EFFICIENCY. ALL MAKE IT SIMPLE
MISTER CHAIR OF. THE PORTS ONLY
ABOUT ART ONLY ABOUT VOLUME
THERE ALSO ABOUT VELOCITY AND
MEANS GETTING THOSE CONTAINERS
OUT OF THE PORT AND ON TO THEIR
FINAL DESTINATION THAT'S THE
GOAL OF THIS TO GET. THOSE
CONTAINERS MOVING IN A MORE
RAPID FASHION WHICH WE NEED.
TO CUT DOWN ON GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
AND AND THE DOLLARS ASSOCIATED
WITH WITH MOVING US CONTAINERS
AROUND THE PORT.
PLEASE RECEIVED.
CARE.
I HAVE NOT ROOM AT THE CALVARY
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION OUR PARKS
BOARD A. B. THIRTY SEVENTY NINE
WHICH GREAT THE. COMPANY
PROFICIENCY FINE.
THE FUND WILL SUPPORT PROJECTS
THAT BEST MOVE AT BEST IMPROVE
VELOCITY THROUGHOUT THROUGHPUT.
RELIABILITY OF THESE IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC ENGINES DIGITIZATION OF
SUPPLY CHAIN INFORMATION ALLOW
TRUCKERS SHIPPERS AND MARINE
TERMINALS TO BETTER PLAN TO
COORDINATE THEIR OPERATIONS.
REDUCING A REDUCING
NONPRODUCTIVE TIMES FOR TRUCKERS
WILL RESULT IN BETTER ECONOMICS
A SMALLER ENVIRONMENTAL
FOOTPRINT AND BETTER SERVICE.
GOOD MOVEMENT IS ESTIMATED TO
SUPPORT ONE THIRD TO THE STATE
ECONOMY AND JOBS.
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG
BEACH ALONE ARE ESTIMATED
SUPPORT ONE IN NINE JOBS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
INVESTMENTS MADE THROUGH THE
CAPITA PROFICIENCY FINE WE'LL
SEND AN IMPORTANT SIGNAL TO THE
THAT CALIFORNIA TENDS TO
COMPETE.
FOR BUSINESS IN TODAY'S RAPIDLY
EVOLVING GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN WE
ASK YOUR AYE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE SPEAKING FAVOR
OF THIS BILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ANDREW AMPS WE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES.
WHILE OF THE PORT OF LA DOES
NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL.
WE VERY MUCH AGREE WITH.
THE FOCUS THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL HAS BROUGHT TO THIS
ISSUE OF SQUEEZING SQUEEZING OUT
MORE EFFICIENCY FROM THE CARPORT
FOOTPRINT IS AN ESTABLISHED
UNDOCUMENTED PRIORITY FOR THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES. WOULD VERY
MUCH LIKE TO WORK WITH THIS
AUTHOR TO SEE THE BILL GO
FORWARD AND TO. ZONE IN ON A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT MAKE SENSE
OF THIS IS A LONG TERM PRIORITY
FOR THE PORT OF LA AND WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE
MEASURE FOR.
I THINK YOU MUCH.
SEE NO THE SPEAKERS ARE THERE
ANY IT IMAGES OF THE PUBLIC EYE
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF WHICH ARE CLOSE
PASSWORD AYE VOTE PLEASE.
COMMENTS I DO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ACTUALLY WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BERMAN AND A SECOND ON
THIS MEDINA.
THE TAPE PEACEFUL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRAZIER.
FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE.
A IT HAS SIX VOTES WILL USCC
ZERO WILL HOPE THROUGH OPEN.
MR ACOSTA AND MISTER FLORA.
IF YOU WALK IN FILE ITEM SEVEN
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE.
MAY PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AND GOD.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR HUG GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THANK RELYING WE TO PRESENT AB
TWO THREE SIX
S. FIVE TODAY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ENSURE THE
MAJORITY OF CRANE OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT NOT
THE BIRD.
THEY'RE ABLE TO REMAIN IN THIS
I COULDN'T RESIST
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO REMAIN IN
BUSINESS SOMEBODY ASKING ABOUT
THAT LIVE THERE. THANK YOU.
.
LET ME GIVE A LITTLE QUICK
BACKGROUND THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION AND SECOND A CURRENT CARB
DIESEL REGULATIONS CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD HAVE A UNIQUE
AND DISPARATE IMPACT ON CRANES
COMPARED TO OTHER TYPES OF
VEHICLES. THAT ARE FORCED TO
FOLLOW THE SAME RULES. THESE ARE
THERE ARE FOR POTENTIAL OPTIONS
THEORETICALLY AVAILABLE TO
GETTING EACH CRAINIC COMPLIANCE
RETROFIT REPOWER PLACEMENT FOR
RETIREMENT.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE WILL
ADDRESS THE CRANE INDUSTRIES
UNIQUE INABILITY TO RETROFIT
REPOWER OTHER EQUIPMENT THAT
OTHER INDUSTRIES MAY NOT BE
EXPERIENCING. IN ADDITION TO
STATE AND FEDERAL EMISSIONS AND
POLLUTION REGULATIONS ON CRANES
THEY ARE SUBJECT TO VERY STRICT
FEDERAL OSHA REQUIREMENTS THAT
REGULATE THE POWER OUTPUT AND
LIFTING CAPABILITIES ON CRANES.
I WILL FOREGO THE REMAINDER OF
THIS BUT THERE'S A LOT OF. IT
BECAUSE OF THE MOTION.
AND I'LL LEAVE IT FOR MY.
MY WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE.
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK ON THIS.
.
BUT SUFFICE IT TO SAY THAT.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT SMALL
ABOUT CRANE OPERATORS OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT WE HAVE
WITH US TODAY FROM VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE STATE.
BOTH IN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORIST DISTRICT MY DISTRICT IN
OTHER DISTRICTS
ARE STRUGGLING WITH.
AND THEY ARE PURCHASED CRANES
THAT WERE COMPLETELY LEGAL WHEN
THEY PURCHASE THEM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THEY ARE BEING
FORCED TO PHASE THEM OUT BECAUSE
OF OF OF COURSE ARE ARE STRICT
ENVIRONMENTAL. A COMPLIANCE
REGULATIONS WHICH EVERYBODY.
AGREES WITH BUT.
WE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT BIG
PICTURE AND BRING IT INTO A
REASONABLE LEVEL AND HERE WE
HAVE THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ARE GOING TO BE POTENTIAL DRIVEN
OUT OF BUSINESS.
SO AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
WILL EXEMPT ALL CRANES FROM
CARDS DIESEL REGULATIONS UNTIL
THE SALE TRANSFER OR NATURAL END
OF SERVICEABILITY OF A CRANE.
PROVIDED IT WAS IN COMPLIANCE AT
THIS TIME OF PURCHASE
AND I BE SEVERAL CRANE OPERATOR
SO RESPECTFULLY I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. AND.
FLORIDA HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR.
FOR THE FIRST TWO OKAY THANK
YOU.
SO WHAT GO AHEAD NOW MOVES
CALMLY INTO CENTRAL AVENUE YOU
REPRESENTS HER.
MY NAME IS MIKE CONNELLY AND I
REPRESENT CHAMPION CRANE ON THE
PRESIDENT CHAMPION CRANE AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. CRANE OWNERS
ASSOCIATION.
SAFETY IS THE NUMBER ONE FACTOR
HERE.
AND FOR CARP TO REQUIRE ME TO
PUT A FILTER ON THIS GOING TO
AFFECT THE HORSEPOWER AND AFFECT
THE CERTIFICATION OF MIGRAINES.
THE CRANES ARE ANSI CERTIFIED
INDIA AND CERTIFIED FOR LIFTING.
AND THE OF THE MANUFACTURERS AND
OSHA WON'T ALLOW US TO MAKE A
MODIFICATION TO THE CRANE
BECAUSE IT'LL.
MAKE IT OUT OF COMPLIANCE
FURTHER CERTIFICATION.
SO THE ONLY THING THAT.
IS LEFT FOR ME TO DO IS REPLACE
THAT.
AND TO GIVE YOU SOME ENOUGH
NUMBER I JUST BOUGHT TEN BRAND
NEW PETER BILLS THAT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A PIECE WHICH
PUT ME IN DEBT.
OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS AND ONE CRAIN
WITH ONE VOTER THERE'S TEN
MOTORS AND TEN PETER'S DON'T.
BUT THERE'S ONLY ONE MOTOR INN A
CRANE THIS TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND THEY RANGE FROM A. THREE
QUARTERS OF A MILLION TO OVER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE RATIO OF.
WHAT MOTORS ARE GOING TO BE
REPLACED?
FOR THE DOLLAR AMOUNT ITS WAY
ASKEW ON THIS
THE SAFETY FACTOR IS THE BIG
FACTOR HERE WE. WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION THAT THE CRANES ARE
SAFE WE DON'T HURT PEOPLE WERE
ALWAYS LIFTING.
HEAVY COMPONENTS AND YOU CAN'T
STOP IN THE MIDDLE OF A LIFT.
AND REGENERATE THE.
THE FILTERS OR IF WE HAVE MEN
BASKETS ARE.
PERSONNEL THAT WERE LIFTING TO
DO JOBS.
WE CAN'T STOP WITH THEM UP THERE
AND.
THESE UNITS
SHUT THE CRANE DOWN CUT THE
HORSEPOWER DOWN RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE LIFT WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC.
IF ANY OF THE WITNESSES MISTER
COSTA.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENT.
AND MY NAME IS KELLY THOMPSON
I'M THE OWNER TIGHTEN CREATING
RINGING. I IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE SPENT MY ENTIRE LIFE IN THE
GREEN INDUSTRY I GREW UP WITH MY
FATHER'S AN OPERATOR. WHEN I WAS
TWENTY TWO I BECAME ONE OF ONLY
TWO WOMEN IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
AS WELL AS THE YOUNGEST PERSON
IN THE STATE'S HISTORY TO BECOME
A CALLOUS OCCURRING INSPECTOR.
I GOT MY FIRST GREEN IT TWENTY
FOUR WHEN I STARTED MY COMPANY
AND ELEVEN YEARS LATER IN.
I HAVE TWENTY CRANES FIFTEEN
EMPLOYEES WERE SIGNATORY OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL UNION.
I'M A CERTIFIED WOMAN OWNED
BUSINESS I SIT ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CRANE OWNERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE AGAIN I'M THE
ONLY FEMALE ON THE ASSOCIATION'S
HISTORY. SO TO SAY THAT I'M A
RARITY BEING A WOMAN OWNED
BUSINESS IN THIS INDUSTRY HAS. A
BIT OF AN UNDERSTATEMENT. AND I
AGREE WITH.
MISTER CONNELLY THE SAFETY
FACTOR IS HUGE AND WE OFTEN HAVE
PERSONNEL AND MAN BASKETS.
IF WE HAVE TO. STOP IN MID
PICKED TO DO A RE CHEN OR
SOMETHING AFFECTS THE POWER OF
THE CREAM. AND WHAT IS SAFE
ANYTHING THAT WE CHANGE ON THE
MACHINE ITSELF IF WE PUT
SOMETHING ON TAKE SOMETHING OFF.
IT WILL VOID OUR LOW CHARTS IT
POINTS OUT WITH THE CAPACITY OF
THE CREAM IS GOOD FOR AND ALL OF
OUR INSPECTION.
.
IT'S ALSO A MASSIVE FINANCIAL
BURDEN. IT'S PRETTY ON. FEASIBLE
FOR MYSELF TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE
MY ENTIRE FLEET ON THE TIME
PERIOD THAT WERE BEING MANDATED.
WE JUST NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME.
YOUR LAST WEEK.
OH YES LAST WEEK I HAD TO CREATE
MY TWO HUNDRED TON CRANE I
PURCHASE IT FOR OVER MILLION
DOLLARS IF WE NOW. HAVE A
CATASTROPHIC ENGINE FAILURE ON
I'M IN ORDER FOR ME TO REPLACE
THAT SAME ENGINE IT'S OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET
IT REPLACED.
BUT WHEN DOING SO IT WILL BE A
TEAR FOR FIVE SO IT WON'T BE IN
COMPLIANCE IN ORDER FOR ME TO
ACTUALLY CHANGE OUT MATURE FOR
FINAL HAVE HE EXPECTS DON. RE
ENGINEER FROM THE MANUFACTURER
NOW WE'RE TALKING ANY.
MUCH LARGER AMOUNT OF MONEY SO
ESSENTIALLY RIGHT NOW THAT CRANE
IS FOURTH SCRAP METAL TO ME.
AT OVER MILLION DOLLARS
FINANCED.
THANK YOU SWEETNESS YES THANK
YOU MY NAME'S TOM PETTY I'M
COUNTY SUPERVISOR OF SAN JOAQUIN
WHICH IS NEARBY I'M ALSO A CRANE
BUSINESS OWNER PROBABLY THE
SMALLEST ONE THE SMALLER CREAM
BUSINESSES.
WHICH BE TYPICAL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND.
THROUGHOUT CITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE WE'RE ALSO HAVE
SIMILAR CRIED BUSINESS AS YOU'D
FIND IN SIGN BUSINESSES AND PACK
MY FATHER'S A FORMER PRESIDENT.
OF THE CALIFORNIA SIGNED
ASSOCIATION AND I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT PRETTY MUCH EVERY CITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
POLE SIGN THE NEED SERVICE THAT
NEEDS A BOOM TRUCK. JUST AS
EVERY CITY HAS AIR CONDITIONING
UNITS ON ROOFTOPS THAT CRANES
LIKE MINE AND MULTITUDES OF
OTHER COMPANIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE WILL SERVICE ON A DAILY
BASIS.
IT IS VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
HAVE A LARGE SCREEN YOU'LL HEAR
FROM A PEOPLE TODAY THAT
REPRESENT THE LARGE CRANE THE
LARGE CORPORATIONS. THAT OWN THE
LARGE GREEN BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY STAND
IN THE IN UP OPPOSITION OF THE
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR TO
STAY IN BUSINESS WHY. FIRST OFF
THEIR CRANE DEALERS.
THEY BUY THEIR EQUIPMENT HOST
CELL THEY PAY FOR THEIR
EQUIPMENT WITH LARGE CORPORATE
ACCOUNTS AND THEY'LL CYCLE THAT
EQUIPMENT OUT OF STATE INTO
ANOTHER YARDAGE IN THE VALUE OR.
ANOTHER NEIGHBORING STATE INTO
THE SECONDARY MARKET THAT THEY
ALSO OWN THEY CANNOT WE CANNOT
PURCHASE THAT VEHICLE FROM THEM
AT THE SAME PRICE THAT THEY.
HOST SALE THAT VEHICLE OUT SO
IT'S STATISTICALLY NOT AVAILABLE
FOR US TO COMPETE WITH THEM AS
THEY BEING A A A LARGE.
EQUIPMENT DEALER THAT ALSO HAS
THE LARGE CORPORATE ACCOUNTS AT
OIL REFINERIES AND OTHER BIG
LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO WE'RE IN
A DIFFERENT BUSINESS MODEL FOR
SOME COMPANIES THEY CAN ABSORB
IT. OTHER COMPANIES LIKE SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE ME THE SIGN
INDUSTRY WITH SMALL GROUP TRUCKS
WE CANNOT ABSORB IT I PULLED UP
SOME STATISTICS EARLIER TODAY IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
THERE WERE FIVE MILLION SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS TRAVELING THE ROAD AN
AVERAGE OF SIXTEEN MILLION MILES
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILES A
DAY.
SO DROPS THE TO CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ROUGHLY TWELVE HUNDRED
CRANES ABOUT TWO HUNDRED OF THEM
ARE GONNA BE ON THE BOOM SIDE.
WITH THOUSAND I'M WOULD BE LARGE
CRANE SUCH AS REPRESENTED BY
THESE TWO BUSINESS OWNERS.
IF YOU AVERAGE PROBABLY ABOUT
FORTY MILES A DAY TRAVELING TO
AND FROM THE JOB SITE AND
RUNNING THAT CREE NO MORE THAN A
COUPLE HOURS IN THE COURSE THAT
DAY. YOU'RE GONNA HAVE NO MORE
THAN FORTY THOUSAND MILES THAT'S
GONNA BE PUT ON THAT VEHICLE
DALY COMPARED TO THE SIXTEEN
MILLION MILES THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO PUT ON
THEIR TRUCKS DAILY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IF YOU DID A
MATHEMATICAL EQUATION WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO CRANE INDUSTRIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR LESS THAN POINT
ZERO TWO PERCENT OF ANY MISSION
THAT'S GOING TO BE CONTRIBUTE TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NICE TO
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES I UNDERSTAND
BEING A GOOD STEWARD AND THANK
CLEAN AIR AND THE VALUE AND
IMPORTANCE OF OF OUR
PARTICIPATION WE'RE WE'RE. I
WILL WEAR IT PLEADING WITH YOU
TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT NOT ALL
BUSINESS MODELS CAN ABSORB WHAT
CARD IS IMPOSING ON.
IT'S A FALSE NARRATIVE THAT
THEY'RE IMPOSING WE CAN'T ABSORB
IT WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WE
TRY TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
THE CARP REPRESENTATIVES TELL US
WE'LL JUST GO AHEAD LEAST BRAND
NEW EQUIPMENT.
WELL THAT JUST DOESN'T PENCIL
OUT IN FACT I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW THE OLDER RANCH IN WINTER.
SHAHRAK AT THE OLDEST CRANE TO
HAVE MY BUSINESS OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT CRANE SONNET
NINETEEN NINETY CARRIER WHICH IT
NEEDS TO BE RETRACTED THE NEXT
YEAR TO A PLAN THAT. YOU KNOW I
HAVE A NINETEEN SEVENTY BLOOM
NOT BECAUSE I LIKE RUNNING AN
OLD BOOM THAT'S THE ONLY BOOM
THAT'S PAID FOR THAT PIECE FOR
MY TWO THOUSAND NINE CREAM IS
NOT GOING TO BE IN COMPLIANCE.
THAT PAYS FOR MY TWO THOUSAND
THREE CRANES THAT COULD BE IN
COMPLIANCE
SO THE STRUGGLES THAT WE HAD TO
STAY IN BUSINESS I'M GONNA
IMPLORE DO YOU UNDERSTAND THIS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES IN THE SIGN AND CRANE
INDUSTRY THOUGH BE AFFECTED YOUR
NEXT DOOR NEIGHBORS AND I WILL
FINISH WITH THIS.
YOUR NEXT DOOR NEIGHBORS THAT
NEED AC UNIT PUT ON THE ROOFTOP
THAT I DO DOZENS OF WEAK. AND
THEIR SET BY HUNDREDS WEAKLY UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THOSE PEOPLE
COULD BE WAITING WEEKS AND WEEKS
AND WEEKS FOR A LARGE
CORPORATION TO COME IN THE SET
THAT UNIT THEY'RE GONNA PAY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. NOT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE
GONNA PAY SMALL OPERATORS LIKE
ME.
SO WE NEED YOU TO UNDERSTAND
THAT OUR INDUSTRY THIS IT'S NOT
JUST ONE SIZE SHOE FITS ALL WE'D
LOVE TO WORK WITH CARD. BUT
CARVE CEREMONIAL THAT WE NEED TO
BUY NEW EQUIPMENT THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THEN LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SINGLE AND ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
OR VOICE THEIR OPINION OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
MR OTHER CUSTOMERS LIKE CLOSE.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NEVERS YEAH AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY FIVE WILL MEAN THE LIFE OR
DEATH FOR MANY SMALL BUSINESS
CRANE ORDERS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND KEEP
THESE COMPANIES AND BUSINESS AND
THEY'RE WELL PAID UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS EMPLOYEES WORKING THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER BECAUSE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO IN HYMNS FLOOR.
I'LL KEEP THIS VERY VERY BRIEF
BUT I THINK AS AS WE DEAL WITH
OUR AIR QUALITY ISSUES AND WE
WORK WITH THE A OR B. I'M COMING
FROM AN AG BACKGROUND AND WE'VE
DEALT WITH THIS. INTRACTABLE
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS OF SOME OF
THOSE THINGS I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH ALL OF THIS
LET'S. LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY TO SEE IF
THERE'S A SITUATION AND A
SOLUTION AND A PATH FORWARD TO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THINK SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
MR COST I SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
CONCERNS THAT WE WERE BROUGHT UP
TODAY BY THE KIND OWNERS.
HOW WE DO HAVE A FIRST BY MR
MATHIS A SECOND BY MISTER PHONE?
I'VE CONSTRUCTION BACKROOM
THIRTY FIVE YEARS SO THE TRADE.
AND I KNOW IT'S HOW EXPENSIVE OF
HEAVY MACHINERY CAN BE AND HOW
RETROFITS CAN COMPROMISE THE
MACHINERY AS WELL. AND WHEN THEY
FIRST BROUGHT IN THE PARTICULAR
FILTERS THEY ARE AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER.
TO THE IN ANY INDUSTRY.
HOWEVER.
A BLANKET EXEMPTION FOR ALL
CRANES OF ANY SIZE WITH NO SET
END DATE OF COMPLIANCE.
IT'S NOT A GOOD APPROACH.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A PATH TO
COMPLIANCE.
OTHERS HAVE DONE IT AND WE CAN
HAVE IT AND WE CAN'T HAVE AN
EVEN PLAYING FIELD.
GOING FORWARD.
I SYMPATHIZE WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THE BUSINESS OWNER
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT IT'S A
FAIR PROCESS.
BUT YEARS INDUSTRY NEEDS TO GET
ENGAGED WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. TO MAKE THEM
UNDERSTAND THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF THEIR DECISIONS TO MAKE ON
YOUR INDUSTRY.
THERE THE REGULATION NAY SET THE
RANKS.
SO WITH THAT RIGHT NOW. AND
EMPLOYEE TO DO THAT.
BE VERY VERY VOCAL WITH THAT
INDUSTRY TO SHARE HOW MUCH IT
IMPACTS YOU.
AND SOMEHOW COME TO A COMPROMISE
ON THAT ONE COMPLAINTS.
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY I CAN'T.
SOME POINT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
BE COMPLAIN THAT'S THE RULES.
SO ONE FIRSTLY RIGHT NOW WAS THE
BILL AS WRITTEN I CAN'T SUPPORT
IT TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER NO FRAZIER NO
FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN NO CHIU.
DALY.
DALY NO FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA KNOWN AS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
FOR THE FOR WILL BE THE ROLE OF
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU EVERYBODY.
MISTER CHIU.
WELL ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE.
WHEN YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE AS A DISTRICT BILL TO ALLOW
THE SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THE S.
OF CTA. TO UTILIZE MANAGED LANES
AS A TOOL TO ALLEVIATE
CONGESTION ON THE I TWO EIGHTY
IN THE U. S. WANNA ONE QUARTERS.
WHICH.
THANK YOU WHICH RUNS THROUGH SAN
FRANCISCO CONNECTS TO SAN MATEO
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES.
WE ALL KNOW ABOUT THE CONGESTION
CRISIS BEING EXPERIENCE IN THE
BAY AREA NOT GOING TO BELABOR
THAT BUT MANAGE LANES HELP TO
INCENTIVIZE CARPOOLING.
TRANSLUCENT PASSENGER EFFICIENCY
WITHOUT ADDING MORE CARS TO THE
ROAD THESE LANES ALREADY EXIST
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND SAN
MATEO COUNTIES CURRENTLY
PERFORMING. ENVIRONMENTAL
EVALUATIONS OF THEIR LANES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO IMPLEMENT MANAGE LANES
DESPITE THE AUTHORITY ELSEWHERE.
ANY DELAY IN GRANTING THIS
AUTHORITY COULD LIMIT THE
ABILITY TO COORDINATE MANAGE
LANES IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH THE
OTHER TWO COUNTIES AND LOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO RELIEVE SOME OF
THE MOST CONGESTED ROUTES IN THE
BAY AREA.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
EFFORTS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AS HIS BILL
PROGRESSES TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND WHAT THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER. TO OUR SPONSOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY ITS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AS WELL AS.
ANOTHER STAFFER CAN HELP ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WHEN I TURN
IT OVER TO MR WHICH I.
CHAIR FOR GOV MISTER CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME ITALY
CHEN A SERVICE IT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR HIS. AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL
AS HE MENTIONED THIS BILL A. B.
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE ALLOWS OUR
COUNTY TO UTILIZE CENTER CLERIC
HOW HE'S. A AUTHORITY THE VTA IS
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE MANAGED
EXPRESS LANES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS WOULD HELP US ALLEVIATE
CONGESTION AND PROVIDE VOTERS
WITH ANOTHER OPTION TO TRAVEL ON
THIS TOPIC I CAN JUST A QUARTER
IN THE BAY AREA. BY EXTENDING VT
IS AUTHORITY TO OPERATE AND
MANAGE LEANS.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE US WITH YET
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY AN OPTION TO
IT ADMINISTRATIVELY MANAGE THAT
A MAN ON THIS ECONOMICALLY
SIGNIFICANT CORRIDOR. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU MENTIONED
THIS WOULD MIRROR SAN MATEO IS
ABILITY TO UTILIZE THE TO USE IT
VTA IS AUTHORITY WHICH WAS
ENABLED WITH PASSAGE OF S. B.
FIVE NINETY FIVE LAST YEAR.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN COORDINATING
REGIONALLY WITH THEM AS WELL AS
ASKS ASSN MATTEO COUNTY AND
SANTA CLARA CALTRANS IN THE TO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
TO ADDRESS CONGESTION IN THE
QUARTER.
DEVELOPING A U. S. ONE A ONE
SOUTH COMPREHENSIVE QUARTER PLAN
THAT LAYS OUT A VISION FOR A
CONNECTION BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO.
SAN MATEO AND SANTA CLARA.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
AUTHORITY TO HELP IMPROVE
ABILITY IN THE BAY AREA AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MIX WITH THIS HEARING.
HAS JUST ONE MEASURE OF AND
HARVEY WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO ADD TO THIS.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME HERE
REPRESENT PLEASE SHIRT JOSHUA
STARK ON BEHALF OF TRANSFORM IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC.
SELECT TESTIFYING SPUR THE
AUTHORS BILL SEEING NOT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FEEL LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THE
AUTHORS BUILD IT WAS OPINION.
SEE NOTE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE LIST BAKER.
THANK YOU ADAM TAKING MISTER CHU
AND I KNOW IT'S A DISTRICT BILL
THAT THE BAY AREA TRAFFIC CAN BE
A WHOLE DISTRICT WIDE ISSUE OUR
CONSTITUENTS MUTUALLY GO TO.
TO GET AROUND.
COUPLE QUESTIONS ON THIS IF
FIRST IS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING I MEAN
THIS THIS COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT WAS SET
UP BY I WANT TO SAY LAST YEAR.
WHY NOT JUST FOLLOW THAT
PROCESS?
CARE THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
LAST YEAR'S BILL.
SP FIVE NINETY FIVE PROVIDED
VTT ABILITY TO. EXTEND ITS TONE
OF THE REDUCE EMITIR COUNTY ONLY
DID NOT INCLUDE SAN FRANCISCO.
SO YOU CAN CHIU GO TO THE CDC
AND ASK
FOR THEM TO DO THIS ARE IN FACT
US SOMEONE A CHAIR FRAZIER IS
BUILT FROM A FEW YEARS AGO AB
ONE NINETY FOUR DOES ALLOW IS
THAT OPTIONS. THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THIS
PROVIDES US YET ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO WITH THE T.
A.'S AUTHORITY ALLOWING FOR A
THREE COUNTY A PARTNERSHIP IN
THE ONE AND ONE QUARTER SO
PROVIDES YET ANOTHER OPTION TO
THE MTC ROUTE. THAT WAS IT
ENABLED THROUGH A CHAIR FRAZIER
IS BILL THAT HAVE YOU TRIED THAT
ROUTE AROUND HAVE NOT WE MIGHT
WANNA WE'RE NOT YET AT THE TIME
OF.
OF BUILDING THESE PLANES BUT WE
WANT TO SET OURSELVES UP TO THAT
WE HAVE A CHOICE OF EITHER
OPERATING.
OPERATING AGENCY TO GO WITH.
BUT IN A DIFFERENT ANSWER TO
THAT IS THE CDC PROCESS IS A
DIFFERENT BODY WITH ITS OWN.
PROCEDURES AND POLITICS AND BY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MOVE
THIS FORWARD THROUGH LEGISLATION
NOT CARE TO GET IT DONE.
IT TAKES AWHILE TO MOVE THINGS
SERIOUSLY TO SEIZE OUR HOPE IS
TO TO MOVE IT THROUGH AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN THROUGH THE SPOT IF WE
CAN.
GOT IT THANK YOU AND THEN THE
OTHER IS.
HOW HOW MUCH OF ELECTED AREAS
WHERE?
THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN ELAINE OUT OF
THIS MY SAY YOU'RE GONNA TAKE A
LANE THAT'S CURRENTLY NOT
DEDICATED IS A HOTLINE.
AND MAKE IT ONE. AS OPPOSED TO
ADD AN ADDITIONAL LANE.
OF TRAFFIC SO THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE ADDING THAT I KNOW THAT
IN MY DISTRICT WE DID ABOUT THAT
RIGHT EVEN IF THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES THE CDC DID. AN
EXTRA LANE IN SOME PLACES TWO
LANES ALONG FIVE EIGHTY INSTEAD
TAKING ONE OUT OF COMMISSION FOR
REGULAR TRAFFIC. AND IT'S
WORKING RIGHT THE MILES PER
HOUR.
INCREASE HAS GONE VERY WELL P.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE GETTING A BIT
MORE BY A. DIFFERENT STORY WAS
SIXTY EIGHTY.
WHICH THEY TOOK AN EXISTING LANE
AND MADE IT A HOT LANE AND
AREN'T EXPANDING.
MORE LANES AND.
HAS I MEAN BURST IT'S FAIRLY
YOUNG I THINK IT STARTED IN
NOVEMBER.
AND MAYBE EVEN THE FIRST OF THIS
YEAR BUT IT'S IT'S DRAMATICALLY
LESS POPULAR AND WHERE. WE HAVE
SEEN MUCH LESS HAVE MILES PER
HOUR. MOVEMENT AT LEAST FROM
JUST
CASUAL OBSERVATION THOUGH IT
SEEMS MORE DATA ON IT HAVE YOU
LOOKED AT THE COMPARISON.
AND WHY NOT ADD ONLY.
SEVEN OF UP SOONER BAKER YES WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF STUDYING
BOTH CONVERTING ELAINE AND
EXPANDING OUR CALLING THE
PAUCITY THROUGH RESTRICTING THE
SHOULDER. PARTICULARLY THE NORTH
BOUND ONTO EIGHTY WE HAVE THAT
EXTRA SHOULDER LANE SO WE HAVE
BOTH. TYPES OF DESIGNS IN OUR
CONCEPTUAL STUDIES AT THE MOMENT
CALTRANS IS ALSO REQUESTED THAT
WE EXAMINED A FLYOVER RAMP
BUILDING A WHOLE NEW RAMP
CONNECTING DIRECTLY FROM ONE A
ONE TO TWO EIGHTY. THAT WILL BE
IN OUR NEXT PHASE OF STUDY WITH
CALTRANS AT THEIR REQUEST.
AND WHERE OF ALTON NEXT WENT
CURIOUS ABOUT IS WHERE THE
DOLLARS GO USE MARKETER ANY PAIN
AND I SEE FROM THE LANGUAGE FOR
TRANSIT WILL IT GO TO ROAD
MAINTENANCE THE POSSIBILITY OF
FINDING RETURN TO SOURCE ON THAT
ROAD WAY OF EXPANDING. SOME
IRREGULAR THE IDEA IS YES TO
KEEP THE FUNDS RATE IN THE
QUARTER IN WHICH THEY ARE
COLLECTED.
CONSISTENT WITH A LOT OF THE
OTHER COOPER QUARTERS IN THE BAY
AREA TERMS OF ROAD MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATION OF FORCE BUT THOSE
ARE THE FIRST CALLS. I WE'VE
TRANSIT AS WELL IN THE QUARTER
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO REINVEST
DOLLARS INTO.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU AYE
I'M.
THAT YOU'RE HAVING A DISTRICT
THAT HAS SEEN SO MUCH CHANGE
WITH HOT PLANES FROM EACH OF THE
LANES AND THE IMPACT IT'S HAD ON
THOSE WHO MAY NOT LIVE IN THE
AREA. BUT ARE AFFECTED BY THE
COMMUTE TRAFFIC I'M I'M HESITANT
ON WHEN THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A
PROCESS THAT ALL OTHER
COMMUNITIES CAN GO THROUGH TO GO
TO THE C. T. SEEING AT THE
STAND.
I APPRECIATE HOW MUCH YOU WANT
TO EXPEDITE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
BUT I I FEEL THAT THAT PROCESS
IS ONE THAT ALLOWS ALL THESE
ISSUES TO BE LOOKED AT BY THE
CDC WHICH WE HAVE ENTRUSTED. AS
A BODY WITH THE AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT.
I CERTAINLY WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVEN MORE LOOKING AT WHAT'S
HAPPENED ON SIX EIGHTY WHERE
THEY TOOK HOLDING OUT OF TRAFFIC
THEY HAVE THE ROOM TO RE STRIPE
AND OTHERWISE IN THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAS HAD.
IN CONTRAST WITH ON FIVE EIGHTY
AND.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWERS.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
SO I HAVE A FIRST BY MEDINA
SECOND BAG YEAR CURRY. MISTER
CHIU WHICH LIKE CLOTHES RESPECT
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SHOOT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS DISTRICT BILL OF FORWARD I
SERVE ON THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
AND WHAT WAS THE AUTHOR OF AB
ONE NINETY FOUR BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND LOCAL PROCESSES CAN
BE VERY INTRICATE IN THE PROCESS
DOESN'T MEAN THE CDC WON'T BE
LOOKING AT THE SAME TIME IN
PARALLEL. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
WHEN ASSEMBLY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRASIER. FRAZIER
IPHONE.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER. BAKER NO
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHU. CHU AYE
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS MATHIS NO
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THAT'S SOUTHERN NEEDS ONE MORE
TO GET OUT WE WILL LEAD ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MISTER FLORA.
SEE YOU AGAIN.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY
SIR.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WHAT PRESENT TO YOU TODAY AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY NINETY NINE WILL CREATE A
CLEAR DEFINITION FOR STAND UP
ELECTRIC SCOOTERS? IN THE STATE
VEHICLE CODE ESTABLISHING RULES
AND REGULATIONS FOR THIS NEW
MODE OF TRANSPORTATION.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE CLARITY FOR
WRITERS LAW ENFORCEMENT CITY
GOVERNMENTS IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
THE STATE LEGISLATOR.
IT ESSENTIAL FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE CLEAR
DEFINITIONS TO THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY WITH THE REGULATIONS
SOMEWHERE TO COMPARABLE TYPE
VEHICLES AND THERE'S A HANDOUT
COMING AROUND TO KIND OF SHOW
THE TOO SIMILAR TYPES OF
VEHICLES.
HEARING THE VEHICLE CODE
COMPATIBLE ALTER ALTERNATIVE
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION AB
TWENTY NINETY NINE CREATES A
BASELINE LEGAL FRAMEWORK. FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD UPON
DEPENDING. ON THE CIVIC
PREDATORY NEEDS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AS A STATE WE NEED TO PROVIDE
CLARITY AND SAFETY. REGULATIONS
FOR WRITERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ALL CREATING SPACE FOR CITIES
WITH VASTLY DIFFERENT ROADWAYS.
CONGESTION PATTERNS AND
REGULATORY STATE.
CONGESTION POWERS TO REGULATE
STAND UP ELECTRIC SCOOTERS THEY
USE AS THEY SEE FIT ON THEIR
STREETS ROADS AND SIDEWALKS.
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
THIS CARL WITH BERT HANSEN
SCOOTERS.
CAR MOVE THE BILL.
PLEASE PROCEED SIR BAG ACTED
AFTERNOON SHARON AND AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON MY CARL
HANSEN DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR BIRD.
BIRD IS A AYE AT BASE STAND UP
ELECTRIC SCOOTER I SHARE
COMPANY.
WE PROVIDE AS SUSTAINABLE AND
ALL AFFORDABLE ALTERNATIVE BUT
TO THE CAR.
THROUGH OUR AFTER ANY IN OUR
BIRDS.
BIRD IS PROUD TO BE A
CALIFORNIA. BASED COMPANY AND
WE.
COMMANDS  YOU IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN MAKING CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADER.
ON.
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION AND
IN ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
THESE ARE GOALS THAT ARE OUR
COMPANY SHARES.
PREDATION IS COMPETING WITH THE
THE CONVENIENCE OF THE
AUTOMOBILE.
UBIQUITOUS CURBSIDE PARKING
SURFACE PARKING LOTS PARKING
MINIMUMS IN ZONING.
CAR BASED RIGHT SHARE APPS
ENSURE THAT GETTING INTO A CAR
IS IS IS ALWAYS EASY.
.
AND AND WE THINK WE HAVE A
SOLUTION TO THE CONVENIENCE
CHALLENGE OF THE THE RECENT
EMERGENCE OF.
TALK WITH SPIKES IN THE BIKES
AND AND AND ELECTRONIC STAND UP
ELECTRONIC SCOOTERS I PROVIDE A
CONVENIENT AND AND SUSTAINABLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR FOR SHORT TRIPS.
AND.
FIRST LAST MILE CONNECTION I TO
OUR EXISTING ALTERNATIVE TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND FOR THAT FOR THE SAKE OF
RIDERS CITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
VEHICLES OF SOME MORE POWER AND
SPEED IN RULES OF OPERATION.
BEAT BE GOVERNED BY SIMILAR
REGULATION AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE.
WOULD TAKE THE REGULATIONS
APPLYING TO CLASS TO ELECTRIC
BIKES AND USER THE SIMILAR
ELECTRONIC BIKES THAT.
WRITERS WOULD BE OUR.
RUNNING ON DOCTOR SPIKE
SERVICES IN AND APPLY THE SAME
RULES TO THE SUMMER WE ACTING.
STAND UP OR ELECTRIC SCOOTER
THAT WE WANT RIDING A BIKE LANES
NOT ON SIDEWALKS.
AND AND YOU KNOW WE DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE TO HAVE A WRITER'S
CONSULT THE VEHICLE CODE WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING INTO IT THAT
TYPE OF VEHICLE THAT'S
PERFORMING THE SAME WAY AS. A AS
A CLASS TO ELECTRIC BIKE USER
SIMILAR SPEED SOME SIMILAR
VEHICLES THEY SHOULD BE
REGULATED THE SAME WAY.
THAT.
REGULATIONS FOR AYE CLASS TO
ELECTRONIC BIKES WAS APPROVED BY
THE STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIFTEEN SO THAT'S THAT'S VERY
RECENT AYE REGULATION AND.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A PART
OF THAT THE TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTION IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
WE HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU THAN ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC STILL LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE REMEMBERS THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOT
FROM CITY OF SANTA MONICA ARE A
CITY OFFICIALS TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS OPTION PRESENTS POTENTIALLY
SUSTAINABLE IN APPEALING THE
MOBILITY. A MODEL FOR OUR
CITIZENS HAVING SAID THAT THREE
WEEKS AGO WE DID DROP IN
OPPOSITION LETTER THAT CONCERNS
ABOUT SAFETY AND HOW THEY'RE
OPERATED AND OUR PARK IS THE
CASE MAY BE. WHETHER UNDER
CURRENT LAW ARE NOT ARE ARE
REFLECTED IN YOUR ANALYSIS
REALLY WELL WANT TO LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW AND THE AUTHOR
KNOW THAT OUR. STAFF IN THE CITY
MANAGER'S OFFICE IN SANTA MONICA
LAST FRIDAY HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THE TRANSPORTATION STAFF'S.
IN THE CITIES OF LOS ANGELES
INSTANCES GO TO CITIES WE ALSO
REPRESENT CITIES WHOSE ELECTIVES
AND AND AND LOCAL REGULATORY
AGENCIES ARE ARE DEALING WITH
SOME OF THE SAME HAS OUR
CONCERNS. CAME UP WITH THE
CONCEPTUAL PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE
ONLY MADE TO THE AUTHORS SPONSOR
IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
SET OF AMENDMENTS THAT MIGHT. BE
A PATHWAY TO RESOLVE OUR CITIES
IS CONCERNS STILL HAS TO BE
CHECKED OFF FORMALLY BY BY
ELECTED AND WHAT NOT BUT WE'RE
HOPING TO WORK WITH. THE AUTHOR
HIS SPONSOR MISTER COMMITTEE.
CHAIR HIS HIS STAFF VICE CHAIR
STAFF.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION
THOUGHT AUTHORS BILL PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ANY REPRESENT
POSITION.
JEFF TONE A CHAIR FRAZIER AND
MEMBERS.
RIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF THE BLIND THE LARGEST
ORGANIZATION OF BLIND AND
VISUALLY IMPAIRED CALIFORNIANS
AND WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT.
THESE LETTERMAN SCOOTERS COULD
BE USED ON SIDEWALKS DEPENDING
UPON. CITY REGULATIONS AND WE
THINK THIS WOULD BE. DEPLORABLE
PUBLIC POLICY. THEY'RE EXTREMELY
QUIET. OWN CHILDREN PEOPLE IN
WHEELCHAIRS PEOPLE WHO ARE BLIND
WOULD HAVE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TASK OF GETTING OUT OF THE WAY
OF SOMEONE WHO. DIDN'T DO NOT
RIDE THESE IN A PROFESSIONAL
MANNER.
IN ADDITION FOR THOSE AREAS
THAT DO NOT HAVE SIDEWALKS.
IN THE THE PEDESTRIAN WOULD BE
COMPETING WITH THESE ELECTRIC
SCOOTERS AND WE THINK AT THIS
POINT ON THIS IS VERY BAD PUBLIC
POLICY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT BIGGER OPPOSITION PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS SYLVIA EAST AND
I AM A CITIZEN I'M A LOCAL
PROPERTY OWNER TAX PAYER AND A
REGISTERED VOTER. LYING HERE IN
OPPOSITION AND THAT'S BECAUSE AS
I AM A FORMER EDUCATOR AND A
PARENT AND A PERSON THAT
FREQUENTLY WALKS ON OUR
SIDEWALKS IN CRISIS STREETS. I
HAVE EXTREME DIFFICULTY WITH
THINGS THAT WON'T MAKE VERY MUCH
SOUND BUT GO VERY FAST. IF I
ACCIDENTALLY COLLIDE WITH
ANOTHER PEDESTRIAN THAT'S SIMPLY
MY SKIN AGAINST THEIR SKIN I CAN
MODEL LIFE I SAY I'M SO SORRY
AND I MOVE ON. IF I GET HIT BY
ONE OF THESE VEHICLES MAY HAVE
AN ADULT PERSON ON IT.
COMING AT ME AT TWENTY MILES AN
HOUR.
THAT'S COULD BE A TWO HUNDRED
POUND VEHICLE OF STEEL AND
ALUMINUM CRASHING INTO ME. THEY
MAY HAVE METAL PROTECTING THEM
AND MAYBE A HELMET I GOT NOTHIN.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A LIFE
CHANGING EVENT SOAPY ALLOW THIS
TO GO THROUGH I'M ASKING PLEASE
YOU STAND IN THAT POSITION IS
THAT IT ME. OR PUT YOUR SPOUSE
OR YOUR CHILD THERE THANK YOU
TAKE YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME AND WE REPRESENT
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD AND
CHAIRMAN.
REPRESENTING MYSELF AS A MEMBER
THE COMMUNITY FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS ANY VOTER.
ARE I'VE BEEN ON THE BAD SIDE OF
THOSE IN THOSE IN A MAJOR
ACCIDENT.
WHERE THE HOSPITAL BILL ONE UP
TO MILLION FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS?
SO IT'S NO FUN BEING HIT.
I WOULD I HAD ESTIMATED THAT IT
WOULD TAKE EIGHTY EIGHT FEET AT
TWENTY MILES AN HOUR FOR THESE
VEHICLES BEFORE THEY WOULD COME
TO A STOP.
PLUS THE DISTANCE I WOULD TAKE
FOR TO COME TO A STOP SO IN
SHORT I OPPOSE THIS.
FOR OF SAFETY OF THE SIDEWALK
OR LIKE TO SEE ALL MOTORIZED
VEHICLE STAY IN THE SAME LANE.
AND ALL PEDESTRIANS AND
SIDEWALKS WERE CREATED FOR
PEDESTRIANS SO I HOPE YOU KEEP
IS FOR PEDESTRIANS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
RAINY EX CALIFORNIA'S IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER ALSO.
IT WAS THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO
TEST Y. IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS THOUGH IT WAS HER
OPINION.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO I MEAN SCUSE ME OF
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
MR MEDINA.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS TO THE
OTHER THAT THAT THE FIRST ONE
IS.
WHERE WHERE DO THEY?
SCOOTERS OPERATE NOW WHERE THEY
PERMITTED TO OPERATE NOW. AND
DOES THE BILL.
CHANGE OR ADDRESS WHERE THE
SCOOTERS.
YEAH.
I THANK YOU.
FOR SOME OF YOUR.
SO.
FOR FIRST LET ME SAY WE DO
SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED THERE AND THAT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WE AT THE AT
THE BIRD INTENDS.
WRITERS OF STAND UP ELECTRIC
SCOOTERS TO RIDE LIKE A BICYCLE.
THE THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT ADDRESSES WRITING ON THE
SIDEWALK IS.
SECTION FIVE FORTY THREE POINT
SEVEN A SAYS A STANDUP ELECTRIC
SCOOTERS A TWO WHEELED DEVICE
THAT HAS HANDLEBARS FLOORBOARD.
THE BASIC DEFINITION.
SUBSECTION PIECE SO EXCEPT APPS
EXCEPT AS PROVIDED IN
SUBDIVISION SEE A STAND UP
ELECTRIC SCOOTER. MAYBE OPERATED
ON SIDEWALKS AND MAYBE PART IN
THE SAME MANNER AND SAME
LOCATIONS AS A BICYCLE MAYBE
PARTS AND THEN SEE IS A LOCAL
AUTHORITY. MAY ADOPT RULES AND
REGULATIONS BY ORDINANCE OR
RESOLUTION PROHIBITING OR
RESTRICTING PERSONS FROM WRITING
OR PROPELLING INSTEAD OF
ELECTRIC SCOOTER ON HIGHWAY
HIGHWAYS SIDEWALKS ROADWAYS. SO
WE AYE ASSEMBLY OUR GOAL WAS TO
LEAVE IT UP TO THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO DECIDE HOW THEY
WANTED TO REGULATE THIS. WE AYE
I THINK BIRD WOULD BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT WHOLE
SECTION WAS NOT PART OF THE
BILLS THAT WAS.
.
SUPPORTED BY THE AUTHOR IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY TO
THEIR SATISFACTION WE REALLY
DON'T WANT WRITERS WRITING ON
THE SIDEWALK.
WERE ACTUALLY ADDING TO IT TO
EVERY BIRDS PHYSICALLY ON THE
FOOTBOARD DO NOT RIDE ON THE
SIDEWALK. AND THE THE ONLY
INSTANCE WHERE WE WOULD IMAGINE
IT COULD BE APPROPRIATE AS IF
SOME SAID HE HAD SOME KIND OF
MIXED USE.
CONCRETE PROMESAS THAT HAD SOME
SECTIONS SET ASIDE FOR FASTER
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION IN SOME
SECTIONS SET ASIDE FOR.
PEDESTRIANS BUT WE REALLY DON'T
WANT BIRDS AND PEDESTRIANS
MIXING UP BECAUSE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED AND
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL THE BILL. AS I UNDERSTAND
IT AND AND AND AND WHY WE ARE
SPONSORING IT IS TO PROVIDE THAT
CLARITY I TWO TWO RIDERS AND
CITIES AND AND
ENFORCEMENT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF.
TO I USED TO FOLLOW UP ON. THE
MISTER MEDINA'S QUESTION THEN OF
WOULD YOU BE.
GIVEN THAT IT'S OF NO CONCERN TO
YOU ONE WAY OR THE OTHER WOULD
YOU BE WILLING TO TAKE OUTSIDE
WALKS AND. I ASK THIS BECAUSE IT
I I APOLOGIZE I HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THIS.
.
I'D WANNA SUPPORTED. TO TO HELP
YOU MOVE THIS ALONG BUT I DO
HAVE CONCERNS WHEN IT COMES TO.
SPECIAL HAD DANCE AREA LIKE LOS
ANGELES WHERE THAT THE SIDEWALKS
ARE IN UNIFORM EITHER. YOU HAVE
CERTAIN SIDEWALKS THAT ARE
EIGHTY YEARS OLD THAT ARE ONLY
MAYBE TWO FEET WIDE IN CERTAIN
LOCATIONS.
NOT EVEN ENOUGH TO HAVE ONE
HANDICAP.
ONE WHEELCHAIR.
.
BEING ABLE TO TRAVERSE AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING.
THE COMPETITION OF ONE OF THESE.
PRODUCTS ANY ANNA WHEELCHAIRS
SO WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO JUST
TAKE OUTSIDE WALKS.
I THINK WE WOULD BE WILLING TO
DO THEIR CERTAINLY TAKE A LOOK
AT I THINK ONE OF THE BEAUTIES
OF THIS BILL HOW IS READ AS IS
GIVEN TO LOCAL CONTROL WE JUST
WANTED TO HAVE. AN OVERARCHING
DIALOGUE THAT THIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN'T WORK ON
AS A STATE AND REGULATE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE WE DO YOU
KNOW EACH ONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
HAS DIFFERENT NEEDS. AND I'M A
FROM A RELATIVELY RURAL
COMMUNITY
SO IS MODESTO FRIEND SINCE THIS
COULD BE GREAT FOR OUR DOWNTOWN
AREA STAND STATE ON ON THE
COLLEGE CAMPUSES THIS COULD BE
GREAT BUT THOSE ARE RELATIVELY
WIDE OPEN SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE
ONE SET OF RULES FOR US. AND WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT SOMEBODY'S
MORE CONGESTION YOU KNOW PLACES
YOU KNOW BURDEN I THINK THE
COMPANY WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
LEGISLATORS WOULDN'T PUT THIS
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE VEIL BUILDING
FOR THE SCOOTERS IN THAT
PARTICULAR LOCATION THEY WOULD
MOVE IT TO WHERE IT ACTUALLY
WORKS AND BENEFITS THE.
COMMUNITY SO I THINK THE WAY
THAT THIS BILL IS WRITTEN NOW
ALLOWS FOR SIGNIFICANT.
AMOUNT OF LOCAL CONTROL.
I DO.
FOR IT BECAUSE I DON'T.
AS AS. AS AS I DON'T THINK I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THAT.
WAS THAT YOUR FIRST. HOME SO
COUPLE THINGS I JUST WONDERING
SO I REALIZE THAT THESE GO
TWENTY MILES PER HOUR. IZURIETA
REGULATE THESE SO THE MAYBE
INITIALLY DURING A PILOT TIME
THAT WE COULD TRY COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY'RE ONLY GOING. MAYBE
EIGHT TO TEN MILES NOT JUST TO
GIVE ME A SHOT.
UMPIRE SUPPORT NEW TECHNOLOGIES
IS NO DEPTH. TO IS ABOUT IT I
REALLY SUPPORT YOU WORKING.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
BICU I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY I THINK YOU SAID
BEFORE IT'S.
EACH COMMUNITIES DIFFERENT
AND.
MAY WORK IN SOME MAY NOT WORK
IN OTHERS BUT THE NUMBER ONE
THING IS THAT NOW THEY'RE
BRINGING NEW TECHNOLOGIES I
THINK THAT MORE AND MORE THAT WE
NEED TO WORK AS PARTNERSHIPS.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WORK I DID TO HEAR
THE TESTIMONY FOR THE OPPOSITION
I TRULY UNDERSTAND. I THINK WE
GREAT JUSTICE MAYBE INITIALLY TO
GET THESE OUT TO SEE HOW THEY
WORK.
NOT EVERYBODY RESPECTS
EVERYBODY RIGHT AND THEY DON'T
ALWAYS WANT TO FOLLOW THE RULES
AND SO THAT'S MY CONCERN WOULD
BE WITH THIS.
YOU KNOW I REALLY LIKE JUST TO
SAY YOU KNOW MAKE SURE YOU STAY
IN THOSE BY PLANES OR WHATEVER
WHERE THE PROPERTY. YEAH.
TIRE IS A SAFETY ISSUE SO.
I'M HOPING THE OF CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AND.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
AND I APPRECIATE I LAUGHED SO
MANUFACTURE SOME ON HOW WE CAN
COME IN AND THERE'S A LOT OF ON
PATROL IN POWER STEP WE CAN
REGULATE THEM ALL DAY LONG WE
COULD THE GOVERNOR'S ON SO I'M
SURE THAT THERE'S A.
WHAT WOULD WE DO CURRENTLY DOWN
THROTTLE EVERY BIRD TED FIFTEEN
MILES AN HOUR?
SAYS TODAY THAT THE TWENTY MILE
PER HOUR CAP AND THERE'S JUST
NEARING THE CLASS TO ELECTRIC BY
DEFINITION.
NEARLY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION YOU SAID.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I.
WITHOUT KNOWING REALLY WELL.
WHETHER THIS THIS THIS IS A
SAFER ALTERNATIVE ALTERNATIVE OR
NOT.
IN PLACES LIKE. IN CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS LIKE IN LOS
ANGELES WHERE. THERE ARE.
.
PACIFIC BIPLANES DEDICATED BY
CLAIMS.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING AT LEAST
TO.
HAVE YOU HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENT
WHERE.
RECOGNIZING THOSE JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE DEDICATED BIKE LANES.
THAT. YOU WOULD NOT BE THIS
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE UTILIZED
ON SIDEWALKS.
SOMETHING TO THAT NATURE WHERE
IT SPEAKS.
IT IT IT IT.
PLACES SPECIFIC WALLS.
AND RESTRICTIONS KNOW I AND I I
GET WHERE YOU COME FROM AN
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW AND THEY
WITHOUT THE CONVERSATION WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE ON KIND TO FIND
SOME OF THE SAFETY ASPECTS OF
THIS. BUT NO ABSOLUTELY IF THERE
IS A DESIGNATED BIKE PATH.
PROBABLY NO REASON HE SHOULD BE
ON THE SIDEWALK SO I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE COULD
ABSOLUTELY.
GET TO.
I'M TAKING THAT S.. AS A ASK.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SEEING NONE.
SO BUT AT THIS POINT TIME WILL
TAKE THAT AS YOU'VE AGREED TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS AND WORK WITH
OUR STAFF.
TO.
HOW PUT BUT THE MINUTES INTO?
PRINT FOR APPROPRIATIONS.
BEFORE APPROPRIATIONS CRACKED.
AND IT DOESN'T HAPPEN WILL
RESERVE THE RIGHT ON THE FLOOR.
YOU ALWAYS DO YES I.
HER.
THANK YOU FRED REALIZING THAT.
SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW THAT NO
OTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THOSE LIMITS OF.
SINCE THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
SO.
WE HAVE THE FIRST BY MR MATHIS
A SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER BAKER.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S A IT'S A
GREAT START WE DON'T WANNA
INTENTIA TECHNOLOGY IN NEW WAYS
OF DOING THINGS.
.
LOVE YOU TO. LOVE IT FOR YOU TO
TRACK THIS COULD SAFETY ALSO.
HOME THAT THERE IS THINGS AGO
FOR THE CONCERN. ARE HURTING
PEOPLE OR OR WHATEVER THAT YOU.
ADDRESS THOSE GOING FORWARD.
AND I LOVE THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE TO LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE AS
HAS BEEN ISSUED WORD WILL AND
WILL NOT WORK.
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CLICK. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE NONSENSE.
MATHIS I MEDINA. MEDINA IDEAS
AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THERE'S FOURTEEN WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE CONTRACTS MEMBERS.
TRANSLATIONS.
MISTER GRAYSON.
IT'S REYES SCENARIO OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY ONE.
PLEASE
SEE WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
THE AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY ONE. FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND THIS
LEGISLATION TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL.
MEMBERS SEVERAL RECENT STUDIES
AND REPORTS PRODUCED BY CALTRANS
UC DAVIS AND THIS VERY OWN
COMMITTEE HAVE CONCLUDED. THAT
TRAFFIC SIGNAL OPTIMIZATION
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND
VEHICLE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
NO THE BILL.
OVER TEN YEARS AGO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSLATES COMMISSION
IMPLEMENTED A TRAFFIC LIGHT
SYNCHRONIZATION EFFORTS
STATEWIDE WITH POSITIVE RESULTS
USING PROP ONE B. FINDS.
THAT'S WHY I HAVE AUTHORED AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY ONE IN ORDER
TO ENCOURAGE CITIES. WITH IN THE
EMPTY SEAT TO FURTHER DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT TRAFFIC SIGNAL
OPTIMIZATION I AM PROUD TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
AUTOMOBILE CLUBS.
STATES THAT EFFECTIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL TRAFFIC OPTIMIZATION
PROJECTS OFFER GREAT BENEFITS TO
MOBILITY TRAFFIC SAFETY. AIR
QUALITY AND REDUCE FUEL
CONSUMPTION FOR THESE REASONS I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LEVEL.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON YAHOO
WITNESSES REPORT PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME NAY REPRESENT PLEASE
ARE MEMBERS. OF THE COMMITTEE
TIM CHIANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
MY CARPENTER WITH THAT MR
CHANG'S COUNTERPARTS TO THE
NORTH WE SUPPORT THE BILL AS
WELL.
IN THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THROUGH LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY OTHER ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC ELECTED
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OR VOICE
THEIR CONCERN ABOUT THE AUTHORS
BILL.
CA NINETY ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
WE DO HAVE ET FIRST BY MR MATHIS
A SECOND AYE MR GIPSON LIKES THE
OFFICE TIME.
YOU GUYS CONTRACTS AND.
A MISTER MISTER CREE SOCIALITE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'VE
THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON THIS
IS AN OUTSTANDING BILL WE HAVE
TO OPTIMIZE OUR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CIVILIZATION.
HIS WIFE THROUGH SP ONE WE'VE
ASKED THE UC.
A SYSTEM TO ALSO DO RESEARCH ON
HOW WE CAN FURTHER THE
UTILIZATION OF CIVILIZATION AS.
A MOVEMENT.
TOOL.
BECAUSE SO WITH THAT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL THEY CAN
THANK YOU PREMIUMS FOR BRINGING
A FORK MAPS ARE GREAT WITH COLOR
ALL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
DOES IT WILL KEEP ROLE PERHAPS
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE'RE GOING TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOW.
.
MS FRIEDMAN YOU A THREE BILLS
DID YOU BRING A SLEEPING BAG.
WE'RE DOING FILE ORDER A. B.
C.'S.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE NUMBER SIX.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
VERY MUCH THANK THE MEMBER THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR HER DEDICATED WORK IN
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD. I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS IS NEGOTIATED WITH
THE CHAIR TODAY AND AGAIN I
THINK YOU CHAIR FRAZIER FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS. IN THIS MEASURE
TODAY ARE PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY THREE IN AN ATTEMPT
TO ADDRESS INJURIES AND
FATALITIES AS A RESULT OF
INCREASING SPEEDS ACROSS THE
STATE.
OUR OFFICE HAS RECEIVED AN
OUTPOURING POURING OF SUPPORT
FROM LOCAL COMMUNITIES TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF INCREASED
SPEEDING AT ITS IMPACTS ON
SAFETY.
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES THE CITY OF
WATSONVILLE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
CITY OF MALIBU CITY OF OAKLAND
ALBERTA ADVOCACY GROUPS IN SANTA
MONICA SAN JOSE SAN FRANCISCO
RIVERSIDE AND OTHERS. HAVE ALL
REACHED OUT UNSOLICITED TO US IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE.
THIS ISSUE BEGAN FOR ME IN
GLENDALE WHICH IS A HORRIBLE
TRAFFIC SAFETY PROBLEM. I'M. WE
ARE A CITY OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
AND WE'VE HAD FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO LIVES LOSS FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO TRAFFIC RELATED
COLLISIONS.
TRAFFIC AND PEDESTRIAN AND
BICYCLE COLLISIONS IN LOS
ANGELES HAVE REACH REALLY
EPIDEMIC PROPORTIONS JUST LAST
WEEKEND IN LOS ANGELES I BELIEVE
FOUR PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES. IN
TRAFFIC COLLISIONS.
WE CAN BEFORE LAST I THINK.
I GLENDALE IMPLEMENTED A BICYCLE
MASTER PLAN AND INVESTED IN ST
ENGINEERING ALL ACROSS THE CITY
IN ORDER TO SLOW THE FLOW OF
TRAFFIC AND ENSURE PEDESTRIAN
AND BICYCLE SAFETY. WE'VE BEEN
ENCOURAGING MORE PEOPLE TO COME
OUT ON TO THE STREETS TO WALK
INTO BICYCLE AND YET BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE AVERAGE
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF DRIVERS
SPEED. I'M SPEED LIMITS HAVE TO
CONTINUALLY BE TO BE REYES EVEN
AGAIN AGAINST THE OBJECTIONS OF
RESIDENTS.
AT THE HEART OF THIS A BILL IS
USING DATA TO IDENTIFY WHERE
SAFETY IS PROBLEMATIC SO NOT
HAVING OF HAVING UNBIASED DATA
DRIVEN APPROACH TO THIS ISSUE.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A TASK
FORCE THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN EVERY SECTOR.
LOOKING AT AVAILABLE RESEARCH
OUT OF ARE MAJOR UNIVERSITIES
UCLA AND BERKELEY AND OTHER
STUDIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
FOCUS ON HOW BEST TO ADDRESS
SEVERE INJURIES AND FATALITIES
AS A RESULT OF SPEEDING
VEHICLES.
.
WE KNOW THAT THE BRAIN WHICH IN
THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE REFINED
THAT THIS IS A BIG ISSUE WE ARE
VERY LOOK VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKE HOLDERS AND THE CHAIR. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL AND TO DO
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO WHICH
IS TO GIVE COMMUNITIES THE TOOLS
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEED. TO
REDUCE THESE COOL TERRIBLE
COLLISIONS AND FATALITIES.
WITHOUT I WILL.
JUST MOVED TO MY ADVOCATES AND
I'LL JUST SAY THAT WE NEVER
INTENDED THIS BILL TO BE A
STANDALONE MEASURE WE KNOW THE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO TO DEAL WITH
ENGINEERING. THEY NEED TO DO
WITH ENFORCEMENT THEY NEED TO DO
WITH EDUCATION THEN TO DO ALL OF
THE EASIER TO TAKES EVALUATION
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THIS IS JUST
ONE TOOL THAT WE THINK IT IS
MISSING RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD INVITE ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO JOIN
US AND GIVE US INPUT UP WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT IN A LOT
OF YOUR COMMUNITIES AND WE WANT
TO MAKE THIS A VERY INCLUSIVE.
OF TASK FORCE THAT WE CAN HEAR
FROM EVERYBODY.
THE GOAL IS TO TRY TO REDUCE OUR
VEHICLE RELATED COLLISIONS DOWN
TO ZERO TODAY WITH ME IN SUPPORT
I HAVE JENNIFER COHEN FROM THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION. AND AMELIA
CRONY FROM FROM CALIFORNIA WHAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CAN HEAR ME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER CHO
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR IT THAT
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AND
LOS ANGELES.
LAST YEAR IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES IN
TRAFFIC CRASHES.
THIS WAS MORE THAN GANG
HOMICIDES.
IT IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
ACCIDENTAL DEATH FOR CHILDREN IN
OUR COUNTY.
TO THIS AND IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
MEREKA STUDIES SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTIVE TO ELIMINATE
TRAFFIC FATALITIES TO AN
INITIATIVE CALLED VISION ZERO.
THE MAYOR AND COUNCIL HAVE
SUBSEQUENTLY DEDICATED TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO MAKE
STREETS SAFER. THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THE RECIPE FOR SAFE STREETS
REQUIRES SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT
IN ENGINEERING EDUCATION AND
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON ONE OF
THOSE ESSENTIAL INGREDIENTS
ENFORCEMENT.
STUDIES HAVE REPEATEDLY SHOWN
THAT SPEED IS UNDENIABLY TIED TO
THE LIKELIHOOD OF A CRASH
OCCURRING AND ITS SEVERITY.
THE NATIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY BOARD STATES THAT SPEED
MANAGEMENT IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
TOOL FOR PREVENTING TRAFFIC
DEATHS.
BUT CURRENT CALIFORNIA'S SPEED
ENFORCEMENT LIVES FORCE
MUNICIPALITIES TO IGNORE THESE
FACTS WHEN SETTING SPEED LIMITS.
LAST YEAR IN ORDER TO ENFORCE
SPEEDS ON OUR HIGH INJURY
NETWORK THE NETWORK OF STREETS
WERE SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
FATE ON SEVERE CRASHES OCCUR WE
HAD TO RAISE SPEED LIMITS
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT LAW.
LET ME REPEAT THAT BECAUSE OF
STATE LAW LOS ANGELES HAD TO
RAISE SPEED LIMITS ON NINETY
FOUR MILES OF OUR MOST DANGEROUS
STREET. THIS IS A LOGICAL AND
NEEDS TO CHANGE
SPEEDS NEED TO BE SEPARATE
SAFETY.
SETTING SPEEDS FOR SAFETY IS AN
EXISTING PRACTICE STATE LAW
REQUIRES THAT WE DO IN YOUR
SCHOOLS WE DO IT ON FREEWAYS IN
FACT THERE'S A STATEWIDE TWENTY
FIVE MILE PER HOUR PIMA THOUGHT
SHE LIMIT ON RESIDENTIAL STREETS
FOR SAFETY. NONE OF THESE
REQUIRE SPEED SURVEYS OR EVEN
CONSIDER THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE. THEY SIMPLY
RECOGNIZE AND PRIORITIZE SAFETY.
PRIORITIZING SAFETY SHOULD
EXTEND TO ALL TYPES OF STREETS.
I'D LIKE TO TALK FOR A MOMENT
ABOUT THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE METHODOLOGY.
THIS INDUSTRY STANDARD WAS
DEVELOPED IN THE MID NINETEEN
HUNDREDS
AND WHILE THE SCIENCE BEHIND AN
OBJECTIVE METHODOLOGY REMAINED
SOUND THE CONTEXT FOR ITS
APPLICATION HAS CHANGED.
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS NO
LONGER LIVE WORK COMMUTE ON
RURAL ROADS.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
SIMPLY ACKNOWLEDGES THAT TODAY
OUR STREETS ARE UNPRECEDENTED
CONGESTED MENAGERIE OF WALKERS
BICYCLIST DRIVEWAYS DELIVERY
TRUCKS STROLLERS CARS
MOTORCYCLES WHEELCHAIRS FOOD
TRUCKS.
PARKING LOTS AND PARK LOTS.
PARTLY IT'S.
AND THAT WE NEED MORE LATITUDE
TO SET SPEECH APPROPRIATE FOR
THESE MODERN CONDITION.
CITIES NOW BEST WHERE THE SAFETY
ISSUES ARE ON THEIR STREETS AND
THEY SHOULD BE PERMITTED TO
ADDRESS THIS.
WE SEE GREATER LOCAL CONTROL TO
ADDRESS OUR SAFETY NEEDS.
CITY SHOULD NOT BE BEHOLDEN TO A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL METHODOLOGY
THAT ARE NECESSARILY COMPROMISES
RESIDENTS SAFETY.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
ABOUT SAVING LIVES PLAIN AND
SIMPLE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
TRANSPORTATION SAFE.
NEXT AUTHORED UNKNOWN REMIND YOU
THAT WE HAVE THE SUPPORT FROM
THE CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FRAZIER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M EMILY A
CROWDED THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF LOS ANGELES WALK IN
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO MAKE
WALKING LOS ANGELES CA
ACCESSIBLE AND EQUITABLE. I'M
YOUR SUPPORT TO SUPPORT A FAMILY
BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE.
UNLIKE MANY CITIES AND TOWNS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA MUCH OF LA IS
DESIGNED FOR THE SWIFT
UNINTERRUPTED MOVE IT OF CARS.
NO MATTER THE COST
PEOPLE WALKING AND BIKING HAVE
BEEN PAYING THE PRICE FOR YEARS
LAST YEAR AS CHEN JUST MENTIONED
MORE THAN A THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE
KILLED OR SEVERELY INJURED AND
TRAFFIC CRASHES IN LOS ANGELES
ALONE. IN THE PAST TWO YEARS
PEDESTRIAN FATALITIES IN LOS
ANGELES HAVE INCREASED EIGHTY
TWO PERCENT.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE EIGHTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE METHODOLOGY IS
THAT OUR SPEED LIMITS ARE
ESSENTIALLY SET BY WHAT DRIVERS
DEEM TO BE SAFE AND REASONABLE.
AND DRIVERS ARE QUITE
COMFORTABLE OPERATING VEHICLES
AT DEADLY SPEEDS ON STREETS
DESIGNED FOR THEM TO DO SO.
THE RESULT IS A DEATH OR SEVERE
INJURY IN LA EVERY SEVEN HOURS.
IN ONE WEEK THIS MONTH IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES A QUICK SNAPSHOT
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST
MENTIONED.
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD FREDDIE
FRAZIER WAS KILLED RIDING HIS
BICYCLE IN EFFORT TO CONTROL HIS
TYPE ONE DIABETES.
FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD ALFREDO ORTIZ
WAS STRUCK AND KILLED WALKING
ACROSS WALK FIFTY SEVEN YEAR OLD
GREGORY MORE WAS STRUCK AND
KILLED ANOTHER CROSSWALK. SIXTY
YEAR OLD CHRISTOPHER WHITE WAS
STRUCK AND KILLED BY HIS BICYCLE
THIS IS ONE WE CAN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES.
NONE OF THIS IS SAFE FOR
REASONABLE.
THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
STATE.
COLLECTIVELY MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE INJURED IN
ONE YEAR OF TRAFFIC COLLISIONS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WERE INJURED.
AGAIN NONE OF THIS IS SAFE WERE
REASONABLE.
YEAH WE UPHOLD THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF GOSPEL.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE WILL
ALLOW JURISDICTIONS TO SET SPEED
FOR SAFETY PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS YES WE
MUST DESIGN SAFER STREETS WHICH
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IS
MAKING PROGRESS ON. BUT CITY'S
LEADING ON VISION ZERO RECOGNIZE
THAT IN ADDITION TO ENGINEERING
EDUCATION WE MUST SET SPEED FOR
THE SAFETY OF KIDS AND SENIORS
INSTEAD OF THE COMFORT OF
DRIVERS IN EVER MORE POWERFUL
VEHICLES.
ONE OF THE FIRST US POLICYMAKERS
TOOK WHEN YOU EXIT A LOT VISION
ZERO WAS A LIMIT SPEED LIMITS TO
TWENTY FIVE MILES PER HOUR IN
NEW YORK. ALONG WITH ENGINEERING
EDUCATION TWO YEARS LATER NEW
YORK'S TWENTY THREE PERCENT
DECLINE IN TRAFFIC FATALITIES
COMPLETELY BOOKS NATIONAL
TRENDS.
WE NEED EVERY TOOL IN STRATEGY
AVAILABLE TO US TO DO THE SAME
IN LOS ANGELES AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OUR STREETS AND SPEED
LIMIT POLICIES ARE WELL PAST DUE
FOR AN UPDATE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS JOSHUA SHOT
WITH CHAU YOUR AUNTS WE FOR CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI YOU'VE HEARD WERE A
VISION ZERO CITY THE MAYOR
AGREES WITH THE AUTHOR THAT
SEVERE AND FATAL TRAFFIC CRASHES
ARE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE ANOTHER TOOL
FOR PROMOTING SAFETY. IN OUR
STREETS WE AGREE THAT SPEED IS
NOT THE ONLY INGREDIENT FOR
SAFER STREETS BUT IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE HAVE MORE
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THAT.
ADDITIONALLY THE CENSUS GOODNESS
WHAT TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
SUPPORTS THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS SINCE FOR
THE BILL.
STEVE ALTOGETHER CALVET BICYCLE%
COALITION ALSO SUPPORT PICK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROL SUMMING UP
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SPORTS.
THANKS VERY CITY OF LONG BEACH
IN SUPPORT.
JOSHUA STARK ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA WALKS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE HITTING MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THERE IN OPPOSITION
OR HAVE NO. OPINION ON THE
AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND HE
REPRESENTING PLEASE FOR THE
RECORD MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
ABOUT COMMITTED TRANSIT UNION.
WE DO HAVE AN OUTPOST POSITION
BUT WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
ONCE WE REVIEW THEM WE WILL
PROBABLY GET A NEUTRAL POSITION
DEPENDING ON THE STAKEHOLDERS.
GET BACK IN PICK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST HIM
CHIANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AGAIN WITH
THE AMENDMENTS. WE ANTICIPATE
GOING NEUTRAL ON WOULD HAVE WE
WOULD DO SO AFTER WE ACTUALLY
SEE THOSE AMENDMENTS IN PRINT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY CARPENTER WITH THE AUTO CLUB
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. ON WE
AGREE THIS IS MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU.
THREE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR VOICE OUR OPINION
OF THE AUTHORS BILL. SAYING NONE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THIS ARE YEAR
CURRY. NAM THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I WAS
HAVING A REALLY HARD TIME WITH
THIS OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TAKING THAT MAN I THINK.
NUMBER ONE SAFETY SAFETY SAFETY
AND WE SHOULDN'T AMEND RIGHT OUT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO YOU SEE
PEOPLE JUST ZOOMING DOWN THE
STREETS NOT PAYING ATTENTION AND
THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF
DISTRACTIONS IN THE CAR CELL
PHONES OR WHATEVER SO. BUT EVERY
CAN DO TO MAKE SURE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING FORWARD.
IT WAS BAKER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AND
PARTICULARLY. UP AS THE TWO
PARTS FIRST IS THERE ARE OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THE TRAFFIC STUDY
THAT'S REQUIRED NOW THAT MAY BE
FLAWED NO RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT
AT WHAT TIME OF DAY IT CAN GO.
INTO THE STUDY CAN BE CONDUCTED
WHAT TIME OF DAY CAN'T BE
CONDUCTED AND WE'VE SEEN THAT.
IN MY OWN COMMUNITY WHICH DOES
HAVE RAILROADS.
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING DRIVEN
TO TO BYPASS MAJOR USING VARIOUS
APPS TO BYPASS MAJOR
THOROUGHFARES AND.
IT'S MORE SOPHISTICATED THAN
JUST ONE SOLUTION AND MAKING
SURE THAT A A STUDY THAT IS.
THOROUGH AND REALLY LOOKS AT
MORE ASPECTS OF HOW SPEED LIMITS
ARE CHOSEN I THINK IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ALLOWING OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
TO HAVE THE THE BREADTH OF TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND EVEN THE
STUDY NOT.
POSSIBLE TO BE CONDUCTED AT A
FLEXIBILITY OF TIME OF DATA
SHOWING PEOPLE ARE YOU SET SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT
AND. AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO GIVE
MANY.
EXAMPLES OF NON RURAL ROADS BUT
ADAM I LIKE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
WILL ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
ALSO AND MAKING SURE THAT.
AS YOU AS YOU LOOK AT THIS
THE.
THE ABILITY OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE.
THEREFORE HAVE MUCH MORE SAY.
IN THE SPEED LIMITS IN THE AREA
I HOPE WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
GOAL.
WITH WHATEVER TOOLS THEY ARE
BUT I ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP UP
ON THAT AFTER THE STUDY IN THE
PROCESS GOES FORWARD THANK YOU.
Q..
SO WE HAVE A.
WE'RE MOTION WITH NO MOTION.
MISTER BERMAN I CARE CURRY
SECOND.
.
MS RIVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
JUST I REALLY APPRECIATE AGAIN
YOUR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS IS
A BIG ISSUE I KNOW IT'S GONNA
TAKE TIME AND. SO I APPRECIATE
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO HAVE THE
TIME TO WORK THIS THROUGH AND I
APPRECIATE THE HELP.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT ON THIS FRIEDMAN.
AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO. TO LOOK AT.
DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES AND HOW
THIS GOES IN AND WE ALL KNOW
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
HOW BECAUSE THIS ONE SIZE FITS
ALL METHODOLOGY WE HAVE NOW
DOESN'T WORK?
AND I DO APPRECIATE MAYOR
GARCETTI'S OF.
CONTACTING ME AND IN SHARING
WITH HIS VISION OF ZERO
FATALITIES US VERY VERY.
HIS PASSION IS WHOSE THEIR AND I
APPRECIATE HIM FOR THAT.
MS FREEMAN YOU WOULD AYE OF
MACON OFFERS IT ALL A JOINT
VENTURE THIS BUT JOINT AUTHORS
BILL WE SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
IT GOES ON THE PATH. IP HONORTO
OF TO WORK THIS TOGETHER HAS A
FATHER'S LOST A CHILD IN A CAR
ACCIDENT THERE'S NOBODY.
AS EGGMAN IS HAVE YEAR CURRY ITS
TALK ABOUT SAFETY SAFETY SAFETY.
WE CAN BE SEVEN.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION AS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. FRAZIER FRAZIER
IPHONE FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
MATHIS NO.
THAT WAS YOUR TOUGH.
EXCUSE ME.
IF YOU.
THAT WAS A TOUGH ONE SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO EUROPE.
THANKS TWELVE THE ONE THAT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WHEN FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU AB A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY EIGHT
AUTHORIZES LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
ADOPT A COMMUTER BENEFITS
ORDINANCE TO EXPAND EX EXISTING.
VEHICLE TRIP PRODUCTION
PROGRAMS.
A.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS
GOAL IS TO HAVE A COMMUTER
BENEFIT PROGRAM FOR LA COUNTY TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASEMISSIONS
REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND
INCREASE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP IT
DOESN'T CONFLICT WITH ANY
SIMILAR PROGRAM ACQUIRED BY. ANY
AIR DISTRICTS AND TODAY I'M TO
TESTIFY VERY BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS MY PATERNAL WITH
LA METRO.
UP OF DECEIT THINK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT BREVITY.
A MEMBERS OF PUBLIC LIKE TEST
FINDS OR THE MEMBERS BILL MISTER
CHAIRMAN SHOTS WERE SHOT WITH
SHUTTER INTO FOUR CITY LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SPORT AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
PULLING MAIENSCHEIN BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION AND
SPORT THINK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THE AUTHORS BILL.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO I DO HAVE A FIRST BY SOME OF
THEM MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY SECOND
BY MISTER GIPSON.
MISS FAMILIES LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
IS FREE WILL BE SPORTY YOUR
BILL TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRING IT. MAPS ARE VERY
PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER. BAKER AYE
BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHU. CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VETTING MEDINA.
MEDINA I'M THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT IS TO LEAVE THE ROLL PIN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
A LIST MOVE ON TO TWENTY A FILE
AND TWENTY AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE MISTER MATHIS YOU'RE UNDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I KNOW PERCENT
A DISTRICTS PACIFIC BILL AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE IN AN
EFFORT TO MAINTAIN THE WESTERN
HERITAGE OF THE RANCHO AREA THAT
EXTENDS FROM THE HORSE BILL.
THANK YOU. THIS IS TO HELP
PEOPLE IN THE HORSE AREA
PRIORITIZE WHO ARE SAFETY AND
WHAT'S UNUSUAL URBAN FORCE
KEEPING AREA IN LOS ANGELES.
WITH THAT I WILL MOVE TO MY.
WITNESS OUR CAIRO MANUAL ROSS
WHO IS HERE REPRESENTING THE
MAYOR AND THE CITIZENS OF
BURBANK TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING TERASA BEHALF THE
CITIES OF BURBANK AND GLENDALE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THIS AS
THE AUTHOR NOTED THE SEVERITY
UNIQUE AREA WHERE PEOPLE LIVE
AND KEEP FORCES IN THEIR
BACKYARD AND OFTEN WRITE THEM
DOWN CITY STREETS. ON THE SAME
STREET BUT DRUG CARS ARE DRIVING
ALONG SO SAFETY IT'S BECOME A
REAL ISSUE IN THIS COMMUNITY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO OUR TO BOTH
BURBANK AND GLENDALE AND FOR
THAT REASON WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY OTHER MID
WITNESSES FOR THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION AUTHORS BILL OR HAVE
WAS AN OPINION OF THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SAY NOT ANY QUESTIONS OF COMEY
IS HIGH HERE CURRY MISTER
MATHESON SEC.
I'M I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT.
.
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS WE ALL
CAN DO IS LEGISLATORS TO GO
VISIT SOMEBODY'S DISTRICT.
AND TO REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE THE FEELING AND.
I WAS TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO WITH THIS FRIEDMAN TO SEE
HER DISTRICT AND I WAS PRETTY
MUCH SHOT THAT THERE'S THESE
BEAUTIFULLY EQUESTRIAN SITES.
RIGHT IN THE LA BURBANK GLENDALE
AREA SO.
I APPRECIATE IT AND IT WAS VERY
EASY FOR ME TO SAY I ON THIS
PHONE TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR THE
TOUR.
WHICH MATHIS.
THANK YOU FOR LOOKING OUT FOR
THE EQUESTRIAN COMMUNITY.
.
A IN MY AREA IN THE COUNTRY IT'S
IT'S COMMON WILL WE STILL HAVE
TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE WHO. DON'T
PAY ATTENTION.
BUT TO SEE YOU BRING IT FORWARD
TO TAKE CARE OF A MORE URBAN
AREAS OF PRE
SHE.
THANK YOU.
IN OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I HAVE A FIRST BY MR MATHIS A
SECOND BY MISTER GIPSON.
.
HIS FRIEDMAN WAS LIKE CLOSE YEAH
HOW TO SAY THAT I'M A HORSE
OWNER I'VE OWNED COURSES MY
ENTIRE LIFE AND I'VE WRITTEN IN
THIS AREA FOR YEARS. AND.
COURSE OWNERS HAVE PARTICULAR
YOU KNOW NEEDS WHEN THEY'RE
RIDING IN THERE AND URBAN AREA
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO REACH
THROUGH TO GET TO THE HIGHWAY
WHICH HAS AN ON RAMP RIGHT THE
MIDDLE THE NEIGHBORHOOD. SOAP
NEIL TO KEEP THOSE PEOPLE SAFE
IS REAL PASSION FOR ME SO I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN HUB OF
THE SPOOL YOUR BILL TODAY
HOWEVER I ASK YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
BETTER DEFINING. WHICH AREAS OF
BURBANK AND GLENDALE YOUR BILL
WILL APPLY TO FOR YOU TAKE THE
BILL UP ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE THAT SKILL.
OKAY THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL FOR. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
HATE BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHU I DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON HI.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA I KNOW THEY'RE IN.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
THANK YOU ALL THE.
W..
THE SURGEON ZERO HE PAROLED AND
PERHAPS MEMBERS MR MATHIS.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
NUMBER SEVENTEEN FILE ITEM IT IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PROCEED WE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN IS
A SIMPLE MEASURE.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE A ARE BE
TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO RURAL COUNTIES.
OR PUBLIC TRIED TO.
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND RURAL
CONTIES.
FOR THE PURCHASE OF CLEAN
VEHICLE.
UTILIZING GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION
FUND ORG GIGI R. F. MONIES.
THESE VEHICLES WILL OPERATE.
AS NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION FOR SENIORS AND
THE DISABLED LIVING.
WITHIN RURAL AREAS.
SENIORS AND DISABLED PEOPLE
LIVING IN RURAL AREAS ARE OFTEN.
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY IS AND
WARREN.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE WHO IS SPONSORING
THE BILL.
AND.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
SO YOU GET.
AHS BEEN AN INTERESTING
AFTERNOON.
.
MY BILLS NOTHING LIKE.
THE TECHNICAL STUFF THAT YOU
JUST HEARD.
CSL.
OF COURSE IS.
WHERE INTERESTED IN THE SAFETY?
AND THE HEALTH OF SENIORS.
I AND CALIFORNIA HAS MANY
SENIORS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ARE WHO SUFFER FROM CHRONIC
SERIOUS ILLNESSES OR MENTAL
IMPAIRMENTS.
THAT LIMIT THEIR MOBILITY AND
THEY ALSO LIVE IN RURAL MOUNTAIN
FOR DESERT COMMUNITIES.
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION OR ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES IS A
PRIME CONCERN. DUE TO LONG
DISTANCES TO THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES.
OUTSIDE THE REGION.
MISSING MEDICAL CARE.
WILL LEAD TO REDUCED HEALTH ANY
INCREASED
ACUTE CARE BECAUSE.
IMAGINE IF YOU WILL.
pTHAT YOU'RE SEVENTY YEARS OLD.
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN DISCHARGED
FROM ACUTE CARE. HOSPITAL
HOSPITAL TO YOUR HOME IN A RURAL
AREA.
YOU'VE BEEN ADVISED THAT YOU
NEED FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS
TREATMENTS FOR THIS CHRONIC
ILLNESS.
NEED YOU KNOW YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS
FOR A MYRIAD OF REASONS HAVE
TRANSPORTATION FOR THE FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS.
WHICH ARE OFTEN FIFTY.
MORE MILES AWAY.
WHAT DO YOU GONNA DO?
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE AVAILABLE.
ONE RESIDENT MENDOCINO COUNTY
SAYS WE HAVE A VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES THE
SERVICE.
BUT WE'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
RECRUITING DRIVERS PARTLY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT PUT THE
WEAR AND TEAR ON THEIR PRIVATE
VEHICLES.
DO HAVE LOCAL TRANSIT SERVICE IN
YOUR AREA OFTEN NO.
DEPARTMENTS ON AGING.
THEY HAVE CONTRACTOR FUNDS OF.
VERY FEW AVAILABLE FOR
CONTRACTOR FOR TRANSPORTATION.
ALL THEIR BUDGET MONIES
IS NEEDED FOR DIRECT SERVICES
PROGRAMS.
AN EXCEPTION HOWEVER.
IN SAN BERNADINE KNOWS RURAL
EASTERN AREA.
THE COMMUNITY HAS A SANTA
BUT THEY CALL I'M RIDER CENTER.
VOLUNTEER PROGRAM WHICH RIDERS
MUST IN ROLE.
THEY MUST RECRUIT THEIR OWN
VOLUNTEER DRIVERS.
AND THEY RECEIVE MILEAGE
REIMBURSEMENTS
TO GIVE TO THOSE DRIVERS.
IN MANY CALIPHAL OF CALIFORNIANS
SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S OVER HALF OF OUR
COUNTIES.
SERVICED SENIORS IS UNKNOWN.
BUT WITH GOVERNMENT POLICIES
ENCOURAGING SENIORS TO AGING
PLACE.
AND WITH THE LACK OF HOUSING
ALTERNATIVES.
THEY'RE CLUSTERS OF VERY SMALL
RESIDENTIAL ENCLAVES OFTEN WITH
VERY POOR RESIDENTS.
THROUGHOUT OUR VERY RURAL AREAS.
WE FEEL THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
DESERVES SERVICE HOLES.
THE TRANSPORTATION PROBLEMS LIKE
AND THEN THE SCENE O. COUNTIES
HAVE STEMMED FROM LOW.
RURAL LOW DENSITY POPULATION
BASE
AND THERE SEPARATED BY MANY
MILES.
MOUNTAINS AND LAKES.
MANY SENIORS THERE NEED
TRANSPORTATION TO FAR OFF
LOCATIONS
SUCH AS SANTA ROSA AND SAN
FRANCISCO FROM THAT SPECIALIZE.
MEDICAL TREATMENTS.
TRANSPORTATION BETWEEN THE TOWNS
AND CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY
SAYS DIFFICULT AND EXPENSIVE.
BECAUSE OF THOSE JUST.
ONE CSL MEMBER STATES FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWO. IN
PRACTICE THE MORE URBANIZED
AREAS ARE SERVICED.
STATEWIDE NON EMERGENCY
TRANSPORT SERVICES FOR HIGHER.
ARE PRIMARILY AVAILABLE NEAR
URBAN SUBURBAN AREAS SUCH AS
ORANGE COUNTY. AND SAN DIEGO
CARE.
IN THE NORTH THESE SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO AREAS FROM SAN JOSE
TO MARIN COUNTIES.
AND EAST.
TO ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES.
MOST OF THESE PRIVATE COMPANIES
APPEAR TO USE MODIFIED AMBULANCE
VEHICLES.
THE WHOLE A SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
HOWEVER ONE EXCEPTION.
IS MEDI VAN I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE HEARD OF IT.
OPERATED BY STANISLAUS.
TRANSIT
WHICH IS AN INEXPENSIVE
RESERVATION ONLY SERVICE.
FROM MODESTO.
TWO OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO IN
PALO ALTO.
ONE USER OF THIS SERVICE RELATED
TO ME.
THAT SHE MUST DRIVE MY GET
TRANSPORTATION FROM HOME HOME
INTO LONELY COUNTY.
TO MODESTO.
I CATCH THE VAN.
TO GET TO UC SAN FRANCISCO TO
MEET WITH HER CARDIOLOGIST.
IF ONE IS NOT FEELING WELL. HE
WHEN THAT SERVICE WILL BE
DIFFICULT.
GETTING OLD. IS INEPT
INEVITABLE.
BEING OLD AND POOR.
IS A CHALLENGE.
BEING SICK IS A GREATER
CHALLENGE.
BEING OLD.
SEC.
AND LIVING IN REMOTE ISOLATED
AREAS CAN BE A BURDEN.
BUT HAVING TRANSPORTATION.
FOR ACCESSING YOUR MEDICAL
NEEDS.
LESSONS
THE CHALLENGES.
WE'RE PROPOSING.
THIS MEDICAL TRANSPORT SOLUTION.
THROUGH THE PURCHASE OF ENERGY
RENEWABLE VEHICLES.
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND.
THAT WILL ADDRESS THE RULES
SENIOR AND DISABLED COMMUNITIES
NEEDS.
AND CONTINUES TO ACHIEVE
SWEEPSTAKES GOAL OF REDUCING
ADMISSIONS.
EMISSIONS.
WE HOPE THAT YOU AGREE.
AND VOTE TO PASS THIS.
WELL SAID. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TEST MY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL
OR VOICE OUR OPINION.
SEEING NONE HE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE THIS YEAR CURRY.
I'M ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WORK DONE THESE KIND OF
PROBLEMS IN MY COMMUNITY AND
RURAL YOLO COUNTY FOR A LONG
TIME WE NEVER REALLY COULD MAKE
IT WORK. ENDED UP BUYING A USED
VEHICLE WHICH PROBABLY WE SHOULD
KNOW BY IN THE LONG RUN.
BET IT SOME YOU KNOW.
AS WE GET OLDER TRANSIT IS THE
NUMBER ONE THING AND FOR US TO
STAY IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
IS IMPORTANT BY WHICH OUR CARS
TAKEN AWAY AND YOUR SHIPPED OFF
TO SOME.
SENIOR HOUSING OUTSIDE OF YOUR
AREA IT'S REALLY UPSETTING AND
TO TRANSPORTATION IS THE LINK TO
KEEP THESE PEOPLE THE
COMMUNITIES KEEPS THEM HELP
HAPPY HEALTHY SOMEONE SO FORTH
SO. I WANNA THANK YOU TODAY FOR
GREEN THIS FOR. AND.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING A BILL THAT.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW THE QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
THIS MATHIS LIKE CLOSE.
MEMBERS AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
YOU HEARD THE TESTIMONY OF. MISS
AND WARNED TODAY.
YOU KNOW OUR RURAL AREAS EXPECT
SHIRLEY NEED TO ACCESS FOR OUR
SENIORS IN OUR DISABLED
POPULATION.
THIS BILL SIMPLY TAKES FUNDING.
THAT IS BEING USED BY THE GIGI
R. F..
AND PROVIDES GRANTS SO THAT
THESE AREAS IN THESE FAMILIES IN
THESE RESIDENTS CAN GET THE
TRANSPORTATION THAT THEY VITALLY
NEED ASPIRIN I'VE OF.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS MA'AM DO YOU
LIVE IN MISTER OF CRAFTS A
DISTRICT I DO NOT I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHO COULD USE ME TO
LOOK AT I'M JUST ASKING. NNOVA.
BUT ZSL REMEMBER MISTER CHAIRMAN
I WORK WITH ARE YOU BUDDY.
ONE DIDN'T REALIZE SHE WAS WITH
YOU.
OF.
THAT BEING SAID MR MATHIS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR.
WELL PROVIDING SERVICE THE
DISABLED NOW ELDERLY IS VERY
IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHO LIVE IN RURAL AREAS AND NEED
TO GET TO THEIR DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS.
THAT SAID I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE HAVE A FIRST BY MISTER
CHIU SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAKER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE CHIU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER. HARPER AYE MATHIS AYE
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA IDEAS ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THERE'S ELEVEN LEAD ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS. WE HAVE ONE
MORE BUILDING A MEMBERS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ITSELF FOR
VOTE ONLY IT WILL NOT BE ANY
PRESENTATION.
THIRTY AB IN EIGHTEEN NINETY
EIGHT MATHIS THAT OF SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE AMP
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
BUSH.
A MOTION BY MISTER BERMAN A
SECOND BY MISS BAKER.
TOTAL.
FRAZIER.
I'VE.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHIU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER. HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA IDEAS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT BILL HAS ELEVEN LEAVES ROLL
UP OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I MEMBERS IF YOU'RE READY WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL.
GOING FORWARD CASE YOU CAUGHT
UP TO GET OUT OF HERE. MADAM
SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE READY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS A TWO ZERO.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I HATE YOU.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CHU ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHIU AYE.
THE CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ONE A BE NINETEEN NO
ONE THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TO
ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AM BAKER.
BAKER I AM BERMAN AND. BERMAN
AYE EIGHT DAILY.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE THAT'S AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TO AB TWO ONE ZERO
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
TO ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY.
VIOLATE INTO AB TWO ONE ZERO
SEVEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RANTS.
I AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE A
DAILY.
GIBSON. GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA AINDA DARIEN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
CURRENTLY IT TENDS ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWO TWO TO FOR
THE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ONE
DAILY.
I'M SORRY FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AIN'T DALY.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
FILE ITEM FIVE A. B..
MATHIS NOT VOTING NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE NINE TO ONE.
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWO THREE SIX
THREE THE CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE
TO ONE NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TO ONE FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FIVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR TO
FOR. CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO GIPSON.
GIPSON NO NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
TO VOTE CHANGE I'D TO KNOW
O'DONNELL NO.
CURRENT VOTE.
FOUR TO EIGHT
.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AND SOURCES
LAST COMMITTEE
PROBABLY WON'T BE HER.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWO THREE
EIGHT ONE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE TO ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I NEED TO.
CHIU AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWO THREE NINE
TO THE CURRENT VOTERS EIGHT ZERO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A BAKER.
BAKER NO CHU. CHU AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON NO MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
VOTE CHANGE GIPSON NO TO I. KNOW
TO NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWO THREE NINE
TWO.
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TO ONE.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWO THREE
FOUR EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TEN TO ONE NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE TEND TO WANT.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWO FIVE SIX
FOUR CURRENT VOTERS NINE TWO
ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. TWO
EIGHT FIVE ONE CURRENT VOTERS
TWELVE TO ZERO MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ AREA.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWO EIGHT
SIX FIVE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
TO FOUR FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CURRENT VOTE NINE TO
FOUR.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTERS
ELEVEN TWO ZERO CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
NAZARIAN
.
NAZARIAN AYE. CURRENT VOTE
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE CURRENT VOTE IS NINE
TO ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY.
THEY DID IT WAS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AM CHIU.
CHIU AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE.
YES MA'AM.
CURRENT VOTING FOURTEENS IS ERA.
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB TWO NINE
FIVE FIVE CURRENT VOTES THIRTEEN
TO ZERO NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
VIOLATE IN TWENTY THREE AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN NINE CURRENT VOTED
SIX TO ZERO FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
MS ARYAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
VIOLATE IN TWENTY FOUR AB THREE
ZERO NINE SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE TWO ZERO FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER
AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I NIGERIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY EIGHT THE CURRENT THREAT
IS ELEVEN TO ZERO CHIU.
DALY.
DALY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTERS THIRTEEN TO ZERO
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN HIVE FINAL VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOURTEEN TO
ZERO.
FILE ITEM ONE.
AB NINETEEN NO ONE CURRENT VOTE
TWELVE TWO ZERO.
DALY. DALY AYE HIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TWO AB TWO ONE ZERO
SEVEN CURRENT VOTE TENSES.
DAILY.
DALY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I'VE FINAL VOTE TWELVE
TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIVE A. B. TO TO TWO
FOR CURRENT VOTE IS NINE TO ONE
DAILY.
DAILY I NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA IN AYE FINAL VOTES
ELEVEN TO ONE.
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWO THREE SIX
THREE CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE TO
ONE AS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN
TO ONE.
FILE ITEM SEVEN WE GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION
.
VIOLATE I'M SEVEN HE BE TWO
THREE SIX FIVE NAZARIAN NOT
VOTING FINAL VOTE FORTY EIGHTHS.
RECONSIDERATION WAS GRANTED.
AB FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWO THREE
EIGHT ONE CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN
TO ZERO THAT'S ARYAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWO THREE NINE
TWO CURRENT VOTE IS ELEVEN TO
ONE. I HAVE A VOTE CHANGE BAKER
DIDN'T KNOW TO AYE.
THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE.
THAT.
FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWO FIVE
FOUR EIGHT CURRENT VOTERS TEND
TO ONE AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE ELEVEN
TO ONE.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWO FIVE SIX
FOUR CURRENT VOTERS THIRTEEN TO
ZERO IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE A FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN CURRENT VOTE
IS THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
VIOLENT IN SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWO
EIGHT SIX FIVE CURRENT A VOTE
NINE TO FOUR NOSE AREA.
NAZARIAN I FINAL VOTE TEND TO
FOR.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTERS
THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
DALY.
FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN A B. TWO
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE IT IN TWENTY A B. TWO NINE
FIVE FIVE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN TO
ZERO.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB TWO NINE
EIGHT NINE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
VIOLATE IN TWENTY THREE AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN NINE FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB THREE
ZERO NINE SEVEN FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB ONE EIGHT
NINE EIGHT CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN
TO ZERO CHIU.
FINAL VOTE.
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO
.
OKAY.
THAT WILL CONCLUDE BUSINESS
POORLY CAL THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. HOW WE
ARE ADJOURNED